اي فكر فيه دين معناته هذا معارض
للعقلانيه فاذا يحاولوا يفسروا ليش صار في
ركنه بالعلوم العربيه الاسلاميه واذا بهم
يعثروا على كتاب هائل مهم جدا كتبوا
الامام الغزالي سماه تهافت الفلاسفه بس ما
قال تهافت الفلسفه اثنين ببعض حتى يقولون
شفته فاذا هذا المتدين اللي بيحيا علوم
الدين هذا اللي قضى على العلم العربي لذلك
بيقولوا انه العلم انتهى مع الغزالي طب
لما نتكلم عن الحضاره العربيه واحنا يعني
هي ازدهرت في فتره لما نقول للحضاره
العربيه يعني نتكلم عن الحضاره في عهد
الدوله العباسيه اعتقد توقف
[موسيقى]
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح
الحضاره العربيه الاسلاميه ليست حضاره
عابره ولا ناقله ولا مترجمه يقول جورج
صليبه نجح المستعمر لما اقنع المسلم
والمثقف العربي ان الدين يقتل العلوم
ويقول كمان ان السردين الكلاسيكيه
المعروفه عن نشاه الحضاره العربيه
وتاثيرها وتاثرها غلط في غلط لما نجي
نتكلم عن تاريخنا واجدادنا والعلم
والحضاره اللي صنعوها وديننا نفهمها
بشكلها الحقيقي
كيفما حصلت فهل فعلا نشر الغزالي كتابتها
في الفلاسفه هما اسقط العلم لدى المسلمين
اذا لا هذا اللي يقوله ضيفي
وكيف انتشر هذا الكلام فتجد العلماء
والعلوم لم يتوقفوا حتى القرن السادس عشر
بينما الغزالي توفي في القرن الثاني عشر
في هذه الحلقه يشرح ضيفي جورج صليبه استاذ
العلوم العربيه والاسلاميه في جامعه
كولومبيا سابقا تاريخ العلوم العربيه
الاسلاميه وكيف نشا نشات عند العرب
الاوائل وكيف كان دور عبد الملك بن مروان
في هذه النهضه التي كان درع باسيين انهم
قطفوا ثمارها
وبعد ان ازدهرت هذه الحضاره كيف تدهورت
بيتفق جورج مع ادم سميث في ان تغير طريقه
تجاره هو سبب انحطاط المعرفه لدى المسلمين
ولازم نتعرف على الاخر ليه تطور كيف نهضت
اوروبا وكيف استفادت من الحضاره العربيه
وايش اثر اكتشاف الذهب اللي يعزله ضيفين
ان النهضه المعرفيه الاوروبيه كان الذهب
سببها هي مثل ما يقول
سرديه بديله بقراءه التاريخ العربي
قبل ان نبدا في عاده صباحيه جديده ستسويها
اقول اليكسا صباح الخير جاوبني باحدث
اخبار العالم من بودكاست الفجر هذه
البودكاست من ثمانيه في حدود عشر دقايق
يعطيك سياق الاخبار بشكل جميل بشكل لطيف
وممتع مو لازم يكون عندك اليكسا لكن
لازم تكون عندك عاده صباحيه لسماع بودكاست
الفجر سواء في طريق يمكن الدوام او وانت
تجهز للدوام اسمع بودكاست الفجر المتاح
على تطبيق ابل بودكاست او اي تطبيق
بودكاست تستخدم
اما الان
لنبدا درست في بيروت درست مش دراجه درست
بالاول وبعدين درج وبعدين درست بعدين قبل
ما اروح لامريكا درست ايضا بالجامعه
الامريكيه ببيروت ولكن
بفتره ما بين
والماجستير
بعدين رحت الكولومبيا في لا رحت ولا رحت
كطالب اعاره تبادل ما بين جامعه ستانفورد
وجامعه الجامعه الامريكيه بيروت كان كل
سنه يبقى عندهم طالب من ستانفورد يجي على
بيروت واحد من بيروت يروح كنت انا منتدب
لسنه 68 لما رحت كنت انا منتدى بالطالب
اللي بيجي من الجامعه الامريكيه
وبيروح
وما ادراك شو جامعه سامبول ان تعرف
بالحديقه تستانفورد في عندهم
المختبر اللي يشتغل
يعني شيلوا ذره من اول
يطلخوها للاخر طوله ميل كامل ميل يعني
حوالي اثنين كيلو ولما هذه الذره تطرق
يصوروا والاشاعات تبعه
ويعملوا كل الاختبارات
حديقه
مزرعه كانت لان مزرعه ورد واسعه حطوا هذا
الاكسلراتور فيها هلا الجامعه الامريكيه
كنت في الرياضيات
تخرجت بالرياضيات وبعدين انتقلت الى اخذت
ماجستير كمان من الجامعه الامريكيه ببيروت
في تدريس الرياضيات
يعني مش فقط الرياضيات انه عم نعرف بالضبط
كيف ننقل الرياضات للطلاب
وشو استراتيجيات التدريس وكيف لازم نقرب
الطلاب على الرياضيات وما يحسبو مثلا اذا
كانت فتاه بالصف
بيقولوا لها اهلها انه انتم النساء ما في
داعي تفكروا بالرياضيات لانه ما مستقبل
هذا التربيه سيئه كنا على الاقل
كنا نهتم بالجوع انه مين اللي معقول
يبحث منيح وكيف نوصل الرياضيات لاي انسان
كان بنت او صبي او شيء حتى على الاقل يكون
الغايه هو درس الرياضيات مش الغايه انه
نصنف النساء بيدرسوا بالفنون
والاداب والباقيين
الهندسه والرياضيات هذا كان
موضع التركيز انه
التوصيل الرياضيات للجميع
هذه كانت الماجستير انت غيرت تخصصك من
الرياضيات اذا بحث
يعني مثلا لما كان بعدني بالجامعه
الامريكيه ببيروت وكنا بعمل الماجستير
دائره اسمها دائره التربيه اللي هو تدريس
الرياضيات عبر دائره التربيه وكتبت اطروحه
كانت يعني انا شاكر في حياتي للاستاذ اللي
كان اسمه نعيم عطيه كان هو استاذ
التربيه ولكن كان يدرس
الناحيه
التربيه النواحي النفسيه في التربيه يعني
اول سنه عم بدخل
في واحد
اسمه جون بيجي اللي هو
سويسري ولكن بيكتب بالفرنسي
وعنده عده كتب بس ما بيعرفوه
بيعرفوه والجامعه الامريكيه ما حدا
بيعرفوا وعنده النظريات
كيف توصيل الرياضيات وانت الولد بصير يفهم
بالرياضيات مثلا بتعلم الاولاد الصغار
اننا نعد واحد اثنين ثلاثه بوصلوا لعشره
بيعطيهم جائزه انه وصل للعشره صحيح وبعدين
بتضل يكفي كفت وبس وصل للميه بس اذا كان
عمره اقل من ثمان سنوات معناتها هذا فقط
عم بيستعمل الذاكره ما عم بيستعمل
الرياضيات المفهوم الرياضيات ان يكون يعرف
مثلا هذا الولد الصغير اللي بيقدر يعد
للميه اذا سالته مثلا سبعه وثمانيه
ما بيعرف فكره انه الارقام والاعداد فيها
عمليه جمع وفيها طرح وفي يعني في العمليات
العقليه اللي بتيجي ما بيقدروا يجردها
ويفصلها عن الذاكره اللي بتكرر الواحد
للميه ولا
عنده نظريات كتبت الاطروحه تبعي بتذكر
تماما عن مفهوم العدد عندهم كانه العدد
فقط للحفظ ولا العدد له قيمه جوهريه بنفسه
بس هذا مشكور نعيم عطيه اهداني عليه بهذا
رحت على ستانفورد حتى اكمل هذه
الاطروحه واكمل كمان دراسات بهذا الاتجاه
تعرفت
على استاذ كمان كان يدرس اللغه العبريه
وهناك كان في مقوله ولا تجال هذه المقوله
شائعا
ان العلوم في الحضاره العربيه
اتت من اليوناني عبر اللغه السريانيه
والسريانيه اختها العبريه يعني
وكنت
ماخوذ بهذه الفكره وكان على اساس احب
اتحراها لما براسي كان انه لا يمكن ان
حضاره تاخذ من حضاره تانيه بدون ما تترك
اثر والاثار هذا لازم نتعقبه طيب ولما
حضاره بتاخد الى لغه اي شيء كنت على الاقل
عندي شويه درايه من وقت اللي بترجم اي شيء
من لغه لجره تانيه تتغير ما في شيء بضل
باقي لذلك حبيت اني اطلع على النصوص
السريانيه اللي انتقلت فيها الحضاره
اليونانيه عبر السرياني حتى من الشرياني
توصل للعالم قديت ست سنوات وانا كان بعدني
بلبنان ادرس السريانيه حتى نشوف شو بالضبط
باقي بالسريانيه من اثار هذه النقله من
الفكر اليوناني الى الفكر العربي
وهناك المفاجاه معناتها لما بناخذ افكار
مسبقه وعالم بيقولوا انه الحضاره
اليونانيه نقلت عبر السريانيه الى العربي
بدون ما يشرحوا لنا ليش ضيعت ست سنوات انا
فتش على النصوص السريانيه العلاقه بالعلوم
واذ بي اجد من بعد ست سنوات تسعه وتسعين
بالمئه حتى ما اولمئه بالمئه تسعه وتسعين
بالمئه من الادب السرياني الباقي لدينا هو
تعليق على التوراه تعليق على الكتاب
المقدس ما له علاقه بالعلوم اطلاقا اطلاقا
ابدا فاذا السنوات الضياعتها
كانت هذه مثل بدها تقول واحد عم بيسيء
هدايتي عم يهديني لمحل تاني اي كتاب
بتفتحه لكنه العلوم بلشت باليونان انتقلت
عبر السرياني وصلت للعرب كثر خير العرب بس
ناموا العرب وعيه اوروبا اخذوها فينا نمحي
كل الدور الوسيط كل هالمشاكل هذه اللي
بتصير الاشياء هذه
تخليت عنها
انه هذا الفكر انتقال من اليونان الى
السرياني الى العربي مبسط جدا جدا جدا
بالعكس مشوه
وهناك انتقلت انه ارجع ادرس السرياني بعمق
اكثر حتى شوفوا وين هو هذا النصوص
السريانيه بس لما بتكون انت طالب تعرف
العربي وعم تدرس سريانه صرت مؤهل انك تعمل
شهاده بالشاميات المقارنه هناك انتقلت انا
فكريا من
تقليد المغول اللي بتقلنا العلوم انتقلت
من اليونان الى العربي انتقلت حتى ابحث في
ضبط شو عملوا هذا العلوم بحاله النقل هل
يعني صرت تشوف انه النقل والترجمه واللغات
اللي تدخل بهذا الامور في الها تعقيدات
اكثر بكثير طيب اذا انا وديت خفت عقيدات
بس ودي قبلها انا علشان افهمها احنا نقول
ان عندنا الحضاره يعني في السردين
ترمي لها ان ان العرب اخذوا من اليونان
مو من السيريانين في فتره ايه يعني لما
وصل النضج العلم العربي من بعد ترجمات
نجمه
حجاج اللي صارت باوائل الفتره العباسيه
صاروا يقدروا يقراوا
النصوص اليونانيه المعقده وصار عندهم
اللغه التقنيه تعاطوا معها ساعتها صار في
نقله من العلم اليوناني مباشره الى ممتاز
طيب انا بدي اعرف اليونانيه نفسها
كيف كيف بدات وكيف انهارت
الحضاره هذه
كمان هي نتيجه
يعني في عده علماء يونان من ايام ما قبل
افلاطون حتى هم يتعاطوا بهذا الامور يعني
معظم الشعوب عنده تصور
للاشياء اللي بيشوفوها بالظاهر مثل المكان
ما بين العرب مثلا في تصور كوزمولوجي
يختلف تماما عن الموجود في اليوناني مثلا
اذا تطلع هلق على النجوم اللي وصفهم
عبد الرحمن الصوفي اللي وصفهم بمنتهى
الذكاء لقى عبد الرحمن شوفي عم بيشتغل
بحوالي سنه 360 370 هجري والتسعميه عم
بيشوف انه قدامه في عنده وصف للكواكب جايه
من اليوناني مباشره وفي عنده وصف ثاني
ياتي من البدو من الحضاره العربيه السابقه
للتعرف على اليوناني وهودي عندهم تصور
للافلام تختلف عن هذا
بكتابه هذا اللي سماه كتاب
الكواكب الثابته اللي هي وصفه 48
تصورات فلكيه
بيعطيك مثلا ابو يوسف الكوكبي اللي اسمه
كوكبه الدب الاصغر
وبيقول ما بين الدب الاصغر والدب الثاني
الاكبر في هناك
كوكبه الثعبان
اللي هو مسميه دراكو باليوناني بقول وانما
العرب يقصد فيها البدو بيقصد فيها الناس
اللي كانوا عم يطلعوا على الصحراء على
النجوم وهن بصحراء صافيه ما في مشكله ما
في غيوم ما في الاشياء حول اللي يقول
وانما العرب بيترك باخر كل وصف
لكوكبه من الكواكب بقول لك شو اليونان
قالوا عنا والعرب
ثعبان هذا العرب كانوا يسموه الاربع نجوم
اللي هم راس الثعبان كانوا يسمون العوائد
اللي هي الابن اللي راجعه بتجمع وبيقول
باقلب العوائد في
الفل الجمل الصغير
يلتفوا حواليه ليحموه لحمايه ليله لانه في
ذئب ومنسم النجوم اظفار الذئب يعني تصور
مختلف كليا عن مكان في اليونان
لجماعهم هو هذا عبد الرحمن الصوفي جمع
اثنين وبيعطي بكل الاوصاف اللي بيعطيها
الفكر اليوناني وبيعطي التراث العربي وكيف
بنفهم مع بعضهم هذا معناته صار العلم
ساعته وصل عيد الفتره البواهيه يعني ودي
ادخل الحضاره العربيه بعد شوي ودي افهم ما
قبل العربي علشان لما ندخل العربيه يكون
عندي فهم كيف انتقلت وش اللي يخلي الحضاره
اليونانيه تاكل يعني
خفتت وما خفت
عنه اللي هو قمه الفلك اليوناني كان يكتب
بالقرن الثاني الميلادي
القرن الثاني الميلادي يعني سنه
وكان هو بالاسكندريه عم بيكتب
والاسكندريه كانت مستعمره يونانيه
هذه لذلك سميت الاسكندريه هذا يكتب على
الفتره هذه وهذا كان قمه المعارف
اليونانيه ولكن تفسير العام
الحضاره اليونانيه نفسها
من الحضاره اللاتينيه يعني اللاتيني اللي
هي مسميها نحن الامبراطوريه الرومانيه ما
شاء الله
امبراطوريه الرومان ما في كتاب فلكي واحد
باللغه اللاتينيه بهالفتره هذه كانوا كل
المعلوماتهم من الدول التي استعمروا واللي
منهم اخذوا اليونان اخذوا الافكار
اليونانيه الفلسفه اليونانيه كل شيء
بتلاقي الفلاش في المشهورين مش من الرومان
العلماء المشهورين مش من هالرنه اخذوهم من
اليونان واليونان
باستعمار الدوله
الرومانيه للاراضي اللي كانت تتحكم فيها
الحضاره اليونانيه صار في خلاف باللغه
انه اولا عود اليوناني ضلوا يحكم
باليوناني ضل اذا جابوا والحضاره
الرومانيه ما بيعرفوا اليوناني كيف
نتعلموا هذه شقه
الحضاره
الرومانيه صار فيها الرومان الشرقي اللي
يسمى بعدين بالحضاره البيزنطيه واللي
[موسيقى]
في عنده
مش تناقضات قد ما عنده اسئله عن معنى
الرساله ومعنى الرساله مثلا في المسيحيه
هل مريم العذراء هي ام الله ام هي مريم
فقط كما وردت الفقراء هل يسوع المسيح هو
ابن الله ولا هو رسول الله كل هذه الاسئله
كانوا بلشوا يطرحوها بالفتره
البيزنطيه وبلشوا يلاحظوا انه في فرق تصور
اليوناني وعن التصور الروماني والحوض
البيزنطيين اللي قالوا امهنم يعتنقوا
المسيحيه فلنبدا عهدا جديدا معناها انه مش
فقط
قبل اللي ما قبل المسيحيه وقالوا انه هلا
نيه يمثلوا المسيحيه وهن يضعوا اساس الحجر
الاساسي في تكوين الفكر الديني المسيحي
التساؤلات اللي صارت بها الفتره عن طبيعه
المسيح عن طبيعه مريم العذراء عن علاقه
المسيح بالله وعلاقه انه النبي ولا مرسل
ولا ابن الله كل الاسئله هذه طرحت
بهالفتره هذه معناتها صار في هذا الشقاق
ما بين الحضاره الرومانيه والحضاره
البيزنطيه والحضاره البيزنطيه
ركزت اكثر على المسائل الدينيه ولذلك تخلت
عن الهه الرمان والباقيين صاروا مهمله هيك
صارت
تنشا بالقرن الثالث الرابع
ميلادي ينشا فكر بقوله بحول الدين المسيح
وفيو تساؤلات اللي هي بتدور بخل العالم
حتى يفهموا الرجال المسيحيه شو هي شو فيها
انه المسيح ابن الله فيها انه مات وقام في
اليوم الثالث شو بيقعدوا فيها هل صوبوه او
مثل ما قال عنه القران الكريم لا صلبوه
ولا قتلوه وانما شبه لهم هذه الاسئله اللي
كانت موجوده من الاصل وموجوده في صلب
الدين المسيحي لذلك
ستصور الفكري والتصور العلمي
[موسيقى]
الذهني في الحضاره البيزنطيه تحول اكثر
الى الابحاث الدينيه
ومنها السبب تخلوا عما كان اليونان
القدامى اتوا به من ايام فيثاغورس ايام
ارشميدس ايام الله افلاطون نفسه اللي كان
يقول انه اذا ما بتتعلم رياضيات ما راح
يمكن انك تسقف عقلك انه الرياضيات هي
باليونان ما في اللي هي تعبير في عرب
ترجمه انه علم التعاليم ان تتمرن العقل
يفكر بتعطيه الرياضيات هي ليست حقيقه
بذاتها هي الرياضيات لتدريب العقل وهذا من
افلاطون
واستمر فيها وصار يميزوا بنات
اللي مسميه الحضاره اليونانيه اللي ماتت
ما ماتت رجعت تعيش عبر التفسير الكنسي
والكنيسه ترجع تقولبها بالمفهوم الديني
اللي هي فهمته الى ان
تجاملت مع الفتوحات العربيه اللي اجت
بالقرن السادس للسابع ميلادي
وهناك نشات كمان نوع من التعارف بين
الحضارات اثنان في تشاؤلات واي حضاره
بتتعرف على حضاره ما بتقول لهم مرحبا يا
اخ بتحلو شو المشاكل اللي عندك وهاي
المشاكل اللي عندي هذا الحوار اللي صار
يوناني فاذا ما مات وانما تقولب بالفكر
بالفكر المسيحي
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
طيب بالنسبه للحضاره العربيه ممكن
قبل تبدا مرحله الترجمه وقبل التلاقي ما
بين الحضارتين العربيه واليونانيه
ايش كان الطبيعه الحضاره العربيه يعني وش
العلوم اللي عند العرب اهل كان في اصلا
علوم ما في شك مثل ما قلت لك انه هلا نيه
هذه الكواكب الاربعه الخمسه اللي هن على
على راس السفينهن اللي سموه العرب كانوا
يسموه العوائد اللي هن الابل يعني ايناس
الابل اللي عم بيلفوا حول الربع اللي سموه
الولد الجمل عم بيحموه هناك في تصور فلكي
موجود قبل ما يتعرفوا على اليوناني اللي
جهلك اصطدموا لما تعرفوا الحضارتين ولما
اجا عبد الرحمن السوفي يوفق بيناتهم حس
انه في نقاش انه الفكر اليوناني بقول شيء
والعربي معناه هذا العرب لم ياتي من الغيب
هذا كان موجود ومؤشر والبدو عم بيعيشه
يعني
اهل الصحراء عم بيعيشوا هذه الاجواء وعم
بسموها بالاسماء اللي هن بيعرفوها
مثلا في كوكب اسمه الناقه مش موجوده
بالفتره اليوناني وهذا كله دخ لوها لانه
هن بيعرفوها بهالشكل بقولوا مثلا الصوره
الثالثه اللي بيقولوا شو بنسمي هذه
الكواكب اللي بتبقى على
رجليه الدب الاكبر في بتطلع على صوره
بتلاقي فيه
على الرجل الاماميه والورائيه الاولى
والثانيه بتلاقي فيه نجمتين قراب على
بعضهم
اليوناني ما بيفسر
بينما بيترجم للعربي
وعبد الرحمن الصوفي كانت تقول هذه هي
الكواكب اثنين القفزه الاولى والثنان
التنين القفزه الثانيه والقفشه يعني
القفزه وبيقول هذه من التراث العربي اللي
بيقول انه قرب الكوكب الكوكب اللي اسمه
الدب الاكبر تحت في الكوكب الثاني اسمه
الاسد وهذا الاسد بيقول كان يوم نائم
مرتاح واذا به يرفع ذنبه ويضرب به الارض
الغزلان اللي كانوا هناك حول الماء
فجر وفزعوا من هذا
فقفزوا القفزه الاولى والثانيه فاذا هذا
التفسير ياتي من الحضاره الصحراويه اللي
كانت معروفه واللي بيثبت لنا اياها
وبيخليها هو عبد الرحمن الصوفي يحافظ
عليها لذلك ما فينا نقول
انه اجت طلاصقه حضاره بالثانيه وبدون ما
يصير في مشاكل وتساؤلات عليها وبدون وما
تمست يعني مثلا وكمان نكمل على ذلك في
اشياء مهمه جدا انه الحضاره اللي نشات في
العلم العربي واللي تبنوا الحضاره
الاوروبيه بعدين واعترفت فيه واخذته هذه
الحضارات مثل عبر ناس مثل عبد الرحمن
الصوفي لصقه الحضرتين اليونانيه
والحضاره العربيه
واستحفظت علينا
لدرجه انه بننتظر حوالي 400 سنه وراها
بيجي بالفاء عشر النهضه الاوروبيه واحد
عالم فلكي اسمه بيتر ابيانوس عم بيكتب سنه
1490 لل1,500 ميلاديه
هذا ابيانوس بيقول نحن ما بنعرف شيء عن
الكواكب
ولكن
بنشوف عنا الوصف اليوناني والوصفه
اليوناني ما بيسمي الكواكب بيقول هذا
النجم في مقدم صوره الدب مثلا يعني
بيوصفوا بجمله كامله
بينما بالحضاره
البدويه لاخلاق اللي كان عبد الرحمن عم
بيوفق بينه وبين اليوناني عاده بيسووا
النجم باسم واحد تلاقي بيقولوا هذا النجم
الفرد هذا نجم
هذا النجم كذا فهذا
بيكتشف
بالعصر النهضه بيكتشف ان الاسماء البدويه
العربيه
اسهل للترجمه للنقل بقى بياخد من عبد
الرحمن الصوفي بنحي ما قالت العرب
وبيدخلهم باللاتيني تساروا هن اسماء
النجوم اللي هلا متعارف عليهم بين
الحديث بعد الاسماء العربيه موجوده
بالسماء والعالم ولكن هذه الافلاك
والاسماء هذه لم تاتي عبر اليوناني اتت
عبر الحضاره العربيه البدويه واللي
اصدقائها عبد الرحمن الصوفي وحافظ عليها
بكتابه ومنها انتقلت الى اللاتينيه واصبحت
هي جزء من العلم الحديث يعني شايف ان
القصه معقده جدا جدا طب لما نتكلم عن
الحضاره العربيه احنا يعني هي ازدهرت في
فتره لما نقول الحضاره العربيه يعني نتكلم
عن الحضاره في عهد الدوله العباسيه اعتقد
توقف الدوله العباسيه اتت واثقه
لم تبدا الحضاره بالدوله العباسيه الدوله
العباسيه اتت من بعد 150 سنه من الحكم
الاموي والحكم الاموي اللي بداوا معاويه
واللي سبب مشاكل هائله لما قام سمى ابنه
يجد العهد قالوا له هذا هذا الكسراويه
يعني الولد ما بيكون
مشاكل ايه يا ولد يحكم وهي ولد له حق
بالحكم لانه كانوا معظمهم بهذه الفتره
الاولى ونجعل الامر شورى بينكم مش انه
الواحد يوصي بابنه ولذلك عبد الله بن
الزبير احتج وعمل الثوره الهائله وبطل
يخلي الناس تجي على الحاج بمكه الا ان
تعطيه البيعه بالاول لانه بيقول انه ما له
حق معاويه يسمي ابنه يزيد ولي عهده معناته
ابنه كبرت سنه مثل الدوله الكسراويه
معناتها صرنا عم نتوارث الحكم وهذا الورث
كل جزء طبيعي اني اعرفه
الملوك كل ما دخلوا على قريه افسدوها ما
بنى هذا الحكم بنى الحكم الذي بيقول ونزلت
في ايه الشورى وهذا الحكم اللي بيقول
ونجحوا الامر شورى بينكم هذا هو التقليد
البدوي لما يموت شيخ القبيله ما يقولوا
جيبوا ابنه مباشره
بجيبو بالقبيله مين اشجع واحد يقول لابيله
وبناءه يتشاوروا بيناتهم هذا النمط اللي
نزلت سوره الشورى حتى تشتكملوا هذا اللي
سبب المشاكل بعدين ما بين الدوله الامويه
وده تواصل الدوله العباسيه كان البيت
مراحل اللي راح ما تنسى الدور الاموي
ولذلك انا بركز
اللي انا بسميه الشرقيه البديله على سبيل
الكلاسيكيه بقول انه لما تطلع
بتقول انه بلش العلم باليونان نقل عبر
السرياني صار بعدين عند العرب كثر الله
خيركم تناموا ونحن بنستلمه وبتصير عشر
النهضه ممتاز
البديله بتقول لا انها لما انتقلت لهم
تطورت العلوم فيها تغيرت العلم من جملتهم
مثلا
الحاكم الاموي اشهر واحد مش معاويه لانه
معاويه كان بالفعل
سياسي بالدرجه الاولى ولا ننسى انه الى
الان لا نزال نستعمل تعبير شعرت معاويه
تتذكر هذا التعبير لازم نضل نعرف شو
معناته وهذا
بالدرجه الاولى تعبير سياسي وتعبير كيف
تطير امور الدوله وما تكون كانت تكسر يكون
تترك مجال
لعدوك ياخذ ويعطي هذا
بعد منه اجا مباشره
بحوالي سنه 685 ميلادي
حكم الاموي انتقل من بني سفيان الى بني
مروان وهنا نشا عبد الملك بن مروان عبد
الملك ابن مروان هو انا بعتبري بيتي انا
يكون نشريه جديده لانه هذا كان تجيه رسائل
الى فتره عبد الملك سوا الرسول عليه
الصلاه والسلام توفي سنه 632 ميلاديه
وهنا عم نتحدث على 685 يعني بعد حوالي
خمسين سنه من بعد وفاه الرسول ولا كانت لا
تجال الدوله الفتوحات العربي تتداول
اقتصاديا بالوضع الاقتصادي القائم يعني
كانت مثلا
البلدان اللي نحن نسميها هلا العراق
وسوريا الى امتداد
البحر الابيض هذه الدول كانت تحت الحكمه
البيزنطي وكانت تتداول بالدينار البيزنطي
والذهب ياتي لهم وهم
يتبادلوا بحاجاتنا اليوميه وهلوم وكانوا
يقبلوا وتركوا الامور كما هي يعني هذا
الزكاء بالفتوحات الاسلاميه منتهى الذكاء
انه بتخلي الوضع الاقتصادي العام من الناس
تعرف وين بتدفع الضرائب ولوين ترسلها وما
بتخرب الحركه بالتجاريه بالسوق لذلك تحافظ
على النقد والنقد حركي مهمه ونحن هلا
بلبنان بنعرف شو قيمه النقد قديش مهم هودي
النقديه اللي كانوا محافظين عليها
باليوناني عبد الملك بن مروان بتيجي رساله
من امبراطور بيزنطيا بيقول له اذا بطلت
ابعث لي رسائل بتبلش فيها بالرسائل بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم
والصلاه والسلام على سيد المرسلين محمد بن
عبد الله قال له انا هايدي مستحدثه هيدي
هالرسائل اذا بتضل لانه اولا انا ما بعترف
بالله تبعك عندي
وبعدين انا ما بعتبر انه الرسول سيد
المرسلين هذه بدك توقفها اذا ما عملتها
هيك ما وقفتها انا رح بطل اعطيك الدنانير
البيزنطيه اللي بتستخدمها بالسوق تبعها
يعني الذهب البيزنطي اللي كان العمله يعني
هذا راح وقف عليك
عبد الملك وين بده عنده
مشكله اقتصاديه هائله اذا بدك توقف تعامل
بالدينار شو بدك تشتغل كيف العالم بدها
تمشي امورها بيروح لعند مين بيروح لعند
ابن عمه اللي هو اسمه خالد بن يزيد بن
معاويه خالد من جهه الثانيه من الامويه
كان من الاول عارف انه في حركه الاقتصاد
تتاكل مباشره على شكل النقود النقود يعني
اللي هي يعني بوزاره الملك هذا النقود
واذا الان بعده صبا او سكه هذه في مدينه
كذا هذا من
بروح لعند خالد بن يزيد وخالد كان يعرف
الامور هذه لانه كان عنده اهتمام بما يسمى
الان الكيمياء علم الكيمياء اللي هو شو
علاقه
المعادن ببعضها وبنقدر نحول من معدن
للثاني حسب الفلسفه اليونانيه او ما بنقدر
هالعلاقات والاسئله اللي كان تشتغل تشتغل
له باله لخالد بن يزيد بقى بقول له لابن
عمه لعبد الملك بقول له بالك ولا يهمك نحن
منحل المشكله
ومنصب دينار جديد شو يعني منصب دينار جديد
معناتها نخلق عمله نقديه مختلفه وبالفعل
انتجها وقدر استحدثها ولا يزال الى الان
عنا مسكوكات القديمه من ايام عبد الملك في
المتحف البريطاني لعنه الله عليه بالمتحف
البريطاني عنا المسكوكات ومكتوب على صفحه
منها الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم يولد
والصفحه الثانيه سلامه على رسول محمد يعني
معناها انه استحدث دينار يختلف عن الدينار
البيزنطي اللي كان عليه سوره الامبراطور
على جحه والجهه التانيه عليه صوره الصليب
لانه تيقولوا انه هيدي العمله هي العمله
المسيحيه مثلا عبد الملك اخد هديته واخذ
يعني صدق ابن عمه عبد الملك
خالد بن يزيد وصك العمله اللي سماها هذا
بيقولوا كمان مما ضربه ايام عبد الملك هذا
موجود معناه هذا استحدثت دوله جديده
ولاحظ كمان ايام عبد لذلك انا بعطي اهميه
كبرى لعبد الملك بظن هو اهم حاكم او اهم
خليفه مره بالفتره الاسلاميه في خلافات
ناس بيحبوا اكثر العباسيين ما بعرف ليه
بقولوا انه الامويين هم اساس العرق
العربي في الحدا هو على كل حال هو اللي
شكل العمله
يعني صارت العمله العربيه الدينار
واللي هدايه من
خالد بن يزيد لانه كمان لما بتسكر دينار
هتشوف ليش الاشياء مهمه هاي لما تشكل
دينار ما فيك تحطوا ذهب خالص الذهب الخالص
بينطوي ما فيك بعدين
بالاستعمال يذوب لذلك بتحط معه مع الذهب
بتحط نسبه معينه من ما يسمى بالنحاس او
بتحط معه من التنك شوي تفسير صلب بشوي
تقدر تتعامل فيه لذلك نسبه الذهب هي
94% من الاشياء الثانيه باقي السته هي
معادن اخرى واذا بدك تغير نظام الدوله
الاقتصادي كله يا بتنزل نسبه الذهب او
بتطلعها يعني
هالمقاييس الصغيره حاله من لذلك بدك عالم
يكون بالكيمياء تيكون عندهم موازين
مثل خالد ابن يزيد اللي يقول لهم انه نحن
دينار يضاهي الدينار البيزنطي ونسبه الذهب
في طبقه ثابته
مثلث العمله عم بيثبت للاقتصاد اللي عم
بيقوم بحذف ولاحظ كمان عبد الملك ابن
مروان انه حسب السياسه الفتوحات الاسلاميه
انه ما بنجي بنجبر العالم كلهن يصيروا
مسلمين وما بنجبر العالم انه يخضعوا
لامورنا الثاني نترك العالم على سجيتهم
ولكن بدل ما يدفعوا الضرائب لكن
الدوله الساسونيه او يدفع الضرائب
لاسطنبول اللي صارت اسطنبول وهي بالقبل
كانت كانت
الدوله المسلمين اللي هو معاويه كان
يستقبل وبعدين ضل كمان يستقبل عبد الملك
ابن مروان لاحظ انه
حسابات اللي بتيجي للديوان تبعه لاحظ انه
اسم كبير منها بيجي من بلاد المشرق ويجب
اللهجه الساسانيه يعني اللهجه الفارسيه
القديمه
وضبط الحسابات فيها الى تقنيه معينه وكل
دوابين دوله قائمه عليها
واتجاه
الغربيه تاتي من الدول اللي جسم
المقاطعات اللي كانت الحكم البيزنطي وتاتي
فيها الرسائل وياتي فيها
الدخل كمان بحسابات باليونانيه
بقول لهم انا الخليفه قاعد هون ما بين
لغتين ما بعرفهم لا اعرف اليوناني ولا
اعرف
السياسيين الله يرضى عليكم هذه الدوله لا
يمكن ان تحتاج تستمر بهذا الشكل لذلك كلف
احسن قوات كانوا تحديده اللي هو الشهير
حجاج بن يوسف الثقفي الحجاج بن يوسف هو
اللي كلفه عبد الملك بن مروان كلفوا ان
يهدئ ثوره عبد الله بن الزبير حتى العالم
تروح للحج بدون ما تجبر الى اعطاء البيئه
وهذا كان قاسي هذا
القائد الفظيع اللي اسمه الحجاج هذا كان
قاسي لدرجه انه اعداء ثوره بيجي عبد الملك
بيقول له للحجاج بعد في عنا هيدي مشكله
الناس اللي واقفين بعدهم مع علي الى الان
والاشتقاق ما بين الشيعه والسنه ايه بدي
ابعثك للكوفر هديك الايام ما كان في بغداد
بعد بغداد بتجي بالدوله العباسي جدي بعتك
للكوفه وانت تهدئ من روعه وتحددهم وتقول
لهم اذا ما تبعونا واذا ما بيتسموا
للخليفه
حتى بالمدارس الثانويه
كليتنا نغيب الخطبه اللي قام فيها الحجاجه
بالنيوت وهو قاعد بالمسجد الكوفه واللي
شال الكسفيه عن وجهه
متى اضع العامه متى تعرفوني يا اهل العراق
يا اهل الشقاق والنفق نشر عرضهم يعني وقال
لهم اذا امرته باحدكم ان يخرج من هذا
الباب وخرج من الباب الاخر لقطعت وراه
هوبس وقفت العالم
الخليفه اللي هو عبد الملك
نثر كنانته بين يديه
وعظمها فراىاني وجدني اشدها عودا
فرماكم بي
هذا التاسيس الدولي هذا عبد المنعم اللي
قال له انه هذا الدواوين اللي بتضل تيجي
برسائل فارسيه والثاني
وهو تحت كيف ترجمت الدواوين اللي بتجري من
القسم الشرقي
وترجمت الدواوين ايضا في الغربيه اللي كان
واحد منهم اسمه سرجون اللي كان يتحكم
بالديوان هو يبعت وراه الخليفه انه
نشوف قصه الحسابات قال له هلا مش فاضي
يعني واحد يحكي على على الخليفه بهالشكل
هنا قال له لا هو كمان بدنا نتخلص منه
ترجمه هذا انا بسميه
السرد البديل هو تاسيس الدوله الحديثه
اللي الحديثه للفتره الاسلاميه اللي بدا
عبد الملك بن مروان واللي اثمرت ازمرت
يعني خلقت علوم جديده
ترجمات نفسها يعني الترجمات اللي اجت
للديوان ونحن بنعرف عنا شوي لانه بجدال
اللقاء بتاريخ واللي بنعرفه لما الحجاج عم
بيحاول يغني اهل الكوفه انه
يتبنوا
اللهجه جديده واللغه الجديده العربيه
الموظف بالديوان الفارسي بقول له شو بتعمل
بكلمه وايد
التعابير المستعمله في الديوان بقول له
اضف يعني مش تعمل كلمه اضف عليها وشو
بتعمل يعني يسالوا عن حسابات معينه والفاظ
معينه في لهجه الديوان معناتها هذه
النقله الديوان هي النقله الاداريه نقل
اقتصاديه هي بناء دوله تتكلم بلغه جديده
كل هذه الامور لم تحدث في الدوله العباسيه
والبرهان انه العباسيين لما استلموا الحكم
ما بعد
الخليفه اللي نحن عاده يقال عنه مروان
الحمار هذا هو اخر واحد بالدوله الامويه
استلموا بعده ما رجعوا الدواوين للفارسي
او لليوناني اعطوها كما ترك عبد الملك
معناتها عبد الملك اللي اعطى الانتاج
وتسلموا العباسيين لذلك انا بقول انه
العباسيين حسدوا ما انتجهوا الامويين هذا
الحصاد هو اللي خلق الدوله والاستمراريه
وما في شك لما توحدت اجنحه الدوله من
الجهل عبر الفارسيه ومن الجهه اليونانيه
توحدوا تحت اماره وحده تحت رئاسه نجمه
العبد الملك اجت الدوحه العباسيه واستفادت
من هذا الوضع وهذا الثراء اللي اجى وهذا
توحيد الاقتصاد اللي راح فيه الهدر
بالاموال وصارت الاموال كلها تدار من
ديوان واحد وهو الديوان الملكي او الديوان
الخليفه هذا الديوان اللي تحدث
لذلك العباسيين عم بياخدوا هذا الدور
ويعطوا هذا الدور من ناس ما بيعرفوا
الخلفيه اللي تحجزوا فيها وما بيعرفوا حتى
المروان الحمار انا مش كل العالم بيعرفوا
عنه الا بالنكت يعني بحسبوا انه هذا مسحه
ولكن هي امور مهمه جدا وهيك بنصير نعرف
انا بقول بالسردين البديله بن قول نشات
العلوم نتيجه هذا ترجمه الديوان هذا
ينبعنا في فارس النديم يعني النديم اللي
كتب الكتاب الشهير انه كيف نشات العلوم
واللي بيقلنا انه هذا نقله الديوان هو اول
ما نقل من لغه الى اخرى يعني شفنا نقله
الديوان وبعدين تتالى منها
مش بس هيك انا كمان بقول
بهادي السريه البديله بقول انه لما بتطرد
ناس من الديوان يعني طردوا كل الموظفين
اللي كانوا بيحكوا بالفرشه وكذلك الباقيين
اللي كانوا يحكوا باليوناني طردوا من
الديوان طيب شو بيعملوا عن العمل شو اوعوا
لابنائهم انه هلا لغه الدوله هي اللغه
العربيه
بتروحوا بتجيبوا انتم هلا نيه علوم تتفوق
على العلوم اللي بيعرفوها وبتستقوها من اي
مصدر بتجيبوه وده انا بقول هذه حركه
الترجمه هذا الترجمه اللي اجا لتوثيق
العهد الجديد اللي هو العهد الدوله
العباسيه اللي عم تحسد ما انتجها عبد
الملك بن مروان لذلك هلا بقول لم ينشا ولن
ينشا علوم بدون المنافسه لان صاحب اللي
طرد من وظيفته وابنه صار جائع صار مجبور
يدرب ابنه يقول له ليك في عنا علوم اهم من
العلوم اللي اجت بالديوان عندنا علوم
فلسفيه اهم عن علوم فلكيه اهم عنهم طبيه
اهم هودي لازم ترجع تدرسهم حتى نجي على
الديوان بس نجي على مستوى دار الخلافه ما
نجي على مستوى يتعاملوا معنا كما يشاءون
لذلك مثلا يقول حنان ابن اسحاق الشهير
العبادي اللي كان ايام الدوله المتوكل
اللي هي بحواله 860 840
الميلادي بيقول
حنين بن اسحاق انه كان في ديوان خليفه
المتوكل
56 طبيب ينافسوني من بني مله يعني كلهم
نصارى وهو نصراني بس بنفس الوقت هم الذي
يقيدون لي
وهيدي حفظنا اياها ابن النبي
روايه حنان كيف المصائب والويلات التي
المت به كليه من التنافس اللي كان عم يقوم
ما بين الموظفين واللي كانوا في الديوان
لبس هلا صاروا على مستوى مستشارين للخليفه
هذا غير معناتها
كمان صاروا يحصلوا على ترجمات متقدمه صار
يبحث حتى ايام المامون كان يبعت رسائل
للامبراطور البيزنطي يقول له اذا بتعطينا
مخطوطات الفلانيه على المستوى المتقدم نحن
نعطيك اسرع حرب اللي كانوا على حرب الحرب
القائمه على الثغور يعني كل سنه كان فيه
غزو للدوله البيزنطيه والسنه الثانيه يبقى
غزوا من الدوله البيزنطيه الى الدوله هذا
التنافس هذا الحاجات الاقتصاديه انا اللي
بقول هيدي بعثت البحث عن العلوم وين ما
كانت هذه العلوم اللي جواها
ترجموها مثل ما عملوا
المقطع جاب العلوم كمان
منهم جاب كليله ودنه
والباقيين اللي جابوا العلوم الثاني من
اليوناني ودخلوها بس على هذا المستوى
والبرهان انه حتى بايام بس للتاريخ بغض
النظر عن العلوم بتلاقي مثلا
خلافه المتوكل اللي هي اوائل الدوله
العباسيه كمان بتلاقي كان عنده
اطباء عبد الله بن البختشوع
الكلمه الفارسيه
والاسم نصراني بخفي شو يعني حظ اللي اجانا
من الرب اللي هو يسوع ولذلك توارث هذه
الاماكن كمان من دائما في جبرائيل او بختي
شو بخت شو من ايام الدوله اول الدوله
العباسيه الخلافه المنصور اللي بياتي
يحصد فيها ما اخذه من الامويين
في الديوان تبعه هؤلاء الضلعين هلا
بالعلوم لانه الترجمه اللي
فرضتها الوضع المتنافس من ايام عبد الملك
الى ايام الرسول يعني حوالي مئه سنه هذا
التنافر سبق نقل العلوم خلق والتقدم ياتي
بالتنافس
واقامه المؤسسات التي ترعى وحتى صار كل ما
اللي عنده اموال يطال
ويطلب الكتاب الفلاني اللي يعرف انه موجود
بالاسكندريه يبعت حدا للاسكان بتطب بخصوصي
يجيبه الكتاب من الاسكندريه ويوظف حدا
يترجم له اياه بالعربي بنعرفها الروايات
هذه ما بعرفها لانه صليب
بعرفها
رساله اجتوا رساله من علي ابن عيسى اللي
هو كمان موظف بالدماء بقول له ديوان ايام
الخلافه بقول له قديش عنا ان الكتب
اليونانيه في الطب التي ترجمت
بجاوبه في جوابات الرساله عنا بعد محفوظ
وعنا اياه بالعربي مثل ما حنين وبيقول له
هذا الكتاب الكتاب ترجمه فلان
لبخشوع هذا الكتاب الاخر ترجمه فلان لمحمد
بن موسى بن شاكر هوبس من هذا محمد بن موسى
بن شاكر
انه دماء للخليفه حوده كان يتكل عليهم
الخليج وكان هني يقوموا بهالمشاريع
لاستجلاب العلوم بينما وجدوها هؤلاء اللي
خلقوا اللي انا بسميه العالم بسموه الثوره
العباسيه كله هراء هود التحركات
الاجتماعيه الاقتصاديه والتنافس الاجتماعي
هو اللي خلق العلوم الحديثه حديثه يعني
بفتره الاوائل والعباسيين
اجاهم المجد من حيث لا
[موسيقى]
طيب الان
وش العلوم اللي تميزت في العرب يعني اللي
اقدر افهمها الحين انه اغلب
يعني اغلب الصراع واغلب العلوم اللي ترجمت
للعربيه انها كانت عباره عن انه ناس من
اصول غير عربيه ترجمه وعلومهم الى العربيه
علشان يكون عندهم حظ او فر عند الخليفه
بس فاذا انت تعزز فكره انه كله ترجمه
هو لما بتبدا بالبيت
وتطيح بمدماغ
يتهامر البيت كله بالاخر لما بدات بترجمه
للحاجات
الماسه اللي كانوا اولاد الموظفين في
الديوان يحتاجون اليها ويرجعوا الى
مستشاريه الخليفه على هذا المستوى هذا له
توابع هذه التوابع بصير الكتاب يجر الكتاب
الاخر وهذا الشرح للكتاب الاول فنترجم
الشرح لذلك تتمدد هذا يعني مش عمليه كتاب
واحد مش عمليه نلاقي واحد يعرف يوناني ولا
يعرف عربي لا ناس بيعرف يوناني وبيعرف
سرياني ويتناقش لدرج بهذه الرساله حنين
اللي بيبعتها لعلي بنعيشها وبيقول له ترجم
من كتب جالينا كذا وكذا وكذا وبيقول له
وهذا الكتاب انا ترجمته لابن طيفور وانما
طلب مني ان ابقيهم بالسريانيه
معناتها عم بحافظ على اللغه كلغه
سريه ينافس فيها الاطباء اربعين لو تركها
بالعربي صار كل العالم بيعرفوا قال له هذا
بدنا يخلي الكتاب بالشريان يتظل بمحفظه
انا انا يعني بتلاقي
الرسائل
لمعنى الفته
ومحافظلنا اياها الله يرحمه ويكون بعونه
ويحطه بالمجالس العليا
هو ابن ابيعه اللي كتب طبقات الاطباء وجمع
فيها كل شيء بيقدر يعرفه عن حياه الاطباء
ومنهم حنين بالنساق ومنهم هذه الرسائل
وهذه منها ايضا منها كتب انه لين مصائب
اللي اصابه
ومنلاقي انه حنين ميثاق اصيب مش لانه
لم يكن يدري بالامور الطبيه ولكن لاسباب
تقنيه كنيسيه بالدرجه الاولى بهذه الفتره
يعني اللي كانت الحضاره الاسلاميه
تتصارع فيها مع الحضاره البيزنطيه اللي هي
البيزنطيه يمثلون هذه الفتره كانوا الدوله
المسيحيه النصرانيه والباقيين يقولون لا
يا جماعه الله في ان نحن اهتدينا وعنا
القران انزلها الله علينا ونحن على ابناء
حضاره
الخلافات اللي كانت
اذا كانت بس هيدي للتذكير هيدي سوره مريم
هيدي فقط تذكرني انا لا ابشق على مريم
العذراء وانما ابشق عن الايقونه الايقونه
ما لئيمه شكول الخليل
قالوا
عم يبشق على رموز المسيحيه شو بيعمل
الخليفه متوكل ما حكم عليه راح بعث
للمطران السرياني المسيحي وقال له عندك
واحد بجاليتك بيعمل كذا شو بتعمل فيه
معناه بدا تاسيس اللي بعدين نعرف بالدوله
العثمانيه
الملي السيستم يعني نظام الملي يعني
الخليفه لا يحكم بامور دينيه يتركها لا
الديانات هم يحكموا فيها وهذا
نوع من الحريات يعني عم تقلع بقلب الدوله
تعترف في الاسلام وتؤمن بالاسلام تفسح
مجال ايضا لا الديانات الاخرى اللي هضمها
الاسلام واعتنق على اساس ان هودي اهل
الكتاب ولما نتخلص منهم او نجبرهم انه
غيره تركوهم بس كانوا لما يصير في خلافات
فقهيه مثل خلافات كانه الايقونه مقدسه او
مش مقدسه يرجعوا فيها للمطران او اللي كان
يسموه مفريان بدك الايام هذا هو اللي يحكم
فيها خليفه ما يقول له انه هذا كله كفر
لعنه الله عليكم كلكم
لا لا اجبرهم يغيروا ولا اجبرني غير
تقاليدهم هذه التقاليد كانت مستمره وحنين
باننا انه المصائب اللي المت به هي من بني
ملتي يعني الصراع كان قائم على جميع
المستوياته ومستويات معقده ولا يجب تهوينه
يعني نبسطها زي ما هو منبسط من سوء فهمه
بالاخر
انا ودي اعرف
العلوم اللي ازدهرت او اللي ابتكرها العرب
جراء هذا
دخول المعرفه من حضارات مختلفه اولا اللي
هو مهم جدا جدا بالنسبه للحضاره الاسلاميه
بالدرجه الاولى
عنها حضاره اسلاميه والعربيه نعم اه لا
هذا المشكله انا بخلع التميزات عاده
على اساس لا بستعمل كلمه ارابيك يعني
بمعنى العربيه مش العرب
بالجنس انما اللي يتكلمون العربي حتى كل
العلماء اللي كانوا يشتغلون ولو كانوا من
بني فارس ولو كانوا من بلدان القصوى
بالشرق كانوا لما يجوا بدهم يكتبوا كتب
علميه رزينه يكتبوها بالعربي يعني حتى الى
القرن التاسع عشر تعني انا انا شخصيا
تعرفت سنه 1973 وقت
الاحتفالات الالفيه للبيروني
بجامعه بنص طهران تعرفت على شخص خريج
المدارس التقليديه اللي كانت من الحسينيات
هودي هذا كان يعرف الفرشي ويعرف نفس الوقت
العربي وهو اللي بدينين انا سمعته كلما لو
بتحب اعطيك اياها باللهجه الفارسيه كلما
يعمل في رياضيات العرب ولم يغرى مش يقرا
يقرا انه يخاف بصيرغين بالفير ولم يقرا
الماجستير يجب ان تقطع يده يعني هذا متحمس
للعلوم العربيه لدرجه انه اتقنها وهذا سنه
1973 وفي حياته فات على جامعه هذا خريج
الحسينيات اللي معناته هذا الاستمرار
في درس العربيه انه لازم اذا بدك تعمل
بعلم الفلك لازم تعرف عربي واذا بدك
على هذا الطفل على هذا العلم تقطع يده
يعني لازم تحترم
معناته هذه الحضاره
بقيت وبقيت تتطور
والعربيه كانت لغه العلم لغه نقل هذه
الامور من محل لذين حتى باقاسي فارس كانوا
يتكلموا فيها واش كانت العلوم اللي ازدهرت
في
اولا علم الفلك لانه في ناحيه تانيه مهمه
جدا بعلم الفلك والرياضيات والى علاقه
مباشره بالدين يعني لما كانت
الامه الاسلاميه لا تزال في مكه
وحتى من مكه الى المدينه
تساؤل كان وسالوا الرسول عليه
انه ايمتى يبدا صلاه العصر
فاذا الجواب انه يبدا وقت اللي بيكون قامت
الرجل على طول الظل
وينتهي وقت اللي بصير مرتين
هذا يصح بمكه وهي صاحب المدينه وانما
عندما تصل الى مشارف البلاد الشام الى
بصرى وتشر الى دمشق في الفترات بالسنه
يعني حوالي 20 يوم تقريبا
لا يمكن لظل الانسان يكون بالطول قامته
الظل دائما اطول من خلال فتره الشذى شو
بنعمل فيها
اجوبه من هالنوع اجبرت العلماء المسلمين
ان يدخلو حسابات الفلكيه
بصلب الدين حتى حتى نقيم صلاه العصر اخذت
كتابات وكتابات وكتابات وكل كتابات معقده
ثانيا لما بيشوفوا
عبر الايه القرانيه شهيره حيث ما كنتم
فولوا وجهكم شطره هاتي بسيطه ولكن لما انت
بعيد عن الكعبه شويه بتوصل لبلاد الشام
وانو شطره
وين مقامه ما بتشوفوا بقى شو بتعمل هون
تبدا حسابات المثلثات وحسابات اتجاه
القبله اتجاه القبله يتطلب حسابات مثلثات
وليس مثلثات بسيطه مثلثات على الكره لانه
كان يعرفوا انه يعيشوا على سطح كره
الدوائر على الكره تتقاطع على زوايا
مختلفه لذلك اقيمت هذه الحسابات لمعرفه
توجد القبله
المتطلبه الدين هي
المتطلبات
الطقوس الدينيه هي فرض عليهم تعلم واختراح
علوم جديده لذلك انتشر ولذلك علم الفلك
نتفوق وكذلك العلوم الثانيه واللي كليتنا
بنعرف انه
العلم وعلمان علم
الابدان
يمكن لا
ب
والامور الدينيه
من اول جهه البعثه ترجمه اللي اجت
وطورت الافكار الى تصورات ومسائل جديده ما
كانوا يعرفوها الامور الدينيه اللي واجبه
انه يقوموا فيها قائمه الصلاه والتوجه نحو
الكعبه كل الامور هذه استحدثت وانتشرت
واشتهرت في الحضاره الاسلاميه العربيه
بتحكي عربي هودي هن اللي انا صاروا راس
الحربي لانه كمان لما بتيجي وبتسال فقط
عين تظل
بصير طول قائمه الانسان واذا انت بالمدينه
او بمكه تختلف الامور عما انت في دمشق ليه
هذا بكون عم تستحدث ايضا اللي انا بسميه
الجغرافيا الرياضيه يعني علاقه الوضع
خطوط الطول وخطوط الارض كل هذا صار علم
جديد يدخل فيها كمان
اذا بتاخد نجمات واحد في البيت
تزيحه بجيح البيت كله معه لذلك التوابع
هايده كانت جزء من تكمله
ولكن تفوقوا انا بظن ان العلوم العربيه
تفوقت باستحداث اشياء مهم جدا مثلا
في الفلك اليوناني
وقت اللي كانوا بدهم يحسبون مقدار ميل
الارض لانه ميل قطر الارض
يحدث منه تغيير الفصول فصل الصيف الايام
بعد شويه وقت يجي رمضان والله انعم علينا
رمضان جاي بفتره هلا معتدله
راح تصوم 18 ساعه وقتها ايام الشتاء راح
تشوف بس حوالي 12 معناتها الاختلافات هيدي
مجرد لممارسه الامور الدينيه لازم تكون
تعرف
الجغرافيا ولازم تعرف الرياضيات الجغرافيه
ولازم تكون تعرف الاتجاه القبله
الحسابات الكرويه كل الامور هذه انتاجوا
فيها لانه فقط مش لانه كله من اسباب الدين
ولكن اذا بتفتح باب
الشباك حده بيفتح كمان وصار تلاقي انه في
حاجه لهذه المعارف والمعارف
متداوله بين النجم وطبيعه عندما تتداول
الامور تتنافس على الامور والتنافس هو
المعمار الاساسي لاقامه المؤسسات التي
تحفظ هذه العلوم هذا طيب ليش فيها سرديه
ويبدو انها هي السائده ان
فيه ان العرب هم او الحضاره العربيه
والاسلاميه كانت مجرد ناقل لحضاري يونانيه
ومن ثم رجعت الى اوروبا واتت النهضه لانه
هذا نتيجه السردين الاولى اللي انا هم
الناس اللي هلا بيسموهم بالاسماء الجديده
بسموهم مستشرقين
كانوا يقولوا انتم ارتاحوا ما في داعي
تفكروا ان احنا نفكر عنكم ومن لكم مثلا شو
الفقه الحنبله وشو الفقه الشافعي وشو
الفقه الحنفي نحن بندرسكم ونخبركم عنه
انتو ارتاحوا خليكم تعملوا مثل هذا الفكر
الاستعماري
والفكره الاستعماري اللي بيريح الشعوب عن
الفكر بقول له ان انتو استخيروا نحن بنقول
لكم يعني يتحكموا بمستقبل الفكر الفقهي
حتى تحكموا به هم اللي قالوا يعني هذا
المستشرقين اللي جابوا المستشرقين مشهورين
كل العالم تعرفهم مثل
كلمه
العلماء الالمان اللي هن بداوهم راس الحرب
هذا انه تدرس لو بتستعمر شعب لازم تعرف شو
محركات العوامل هذا الشعب والمحركات
الاساسيه هي المعتقدات الدينيه لذلك قالوا
المقوله الثالثه انه من بعد ما القرن
الحادي عشر ميلادي ما عاد في
مذاهب جديده انه المذاهب هي المذاهب
الاربعه اللي بنعرفها طيب والمذاهب
الظاهريه بالاندلس لا اهملنا لانه ما عاد
الى قيمه
باخضاع الشعوب للاستعمار الجديد هذا
في غايه كانت من تبسيط الامور
وتبسيطها لدرجه انه ما لازم تتساءل نحن
بنعطي الاجوبه هذا نوع من الابويه اللي
متعامل العالم كانه قاصرين هذا اجا من
نتيجه الاستشراق اللي هو وليد الاستعمار
والاستعمار عنده غايه واحده كيف يتحكم
بثروات الناس ما في شيء تاني بهمه فقط اذا
عندك ثروه اذا عندك
مصدر نستفيد منه في التجاره هم يستولوا
عليه هذا الغايه منها كل الباقي
تعليلات كل الباقي يعني محاوله تفسير لما
يحدث على الارض لاسباب سياسيه اقتصاديه
تنافسيه هذه الاسباب الحقيقيه اللي لازم
نبحث عنها وانا بقول انه
لما ننظر الى هذه الامور من هذا المنظار
يتبين عنا اشياء مختلفه كليا عما كنا
نفسر مثلا ليه كان في خلاف ما بين المذاهب
الاسلاميه ليش في خلاف ما بين مذهب ابي
حنيفه ومذهب ابن مالك
وبنلاقي اذا بتنزل بالتفاصيل بتلاقي ايه
في اسباب وجيها بيناتها يعني مثلا مذهب
ابو حنيفه بيسمح انك تقيم وقف ما يسمى
الان بالوقف الاهلي يعني تقيم وقت وتوظف
ابنك مدير للوقف ليه لانه قرانا في القران
والاقربون اولى بالمعروف
فالعالم تستفيد وهذا ابدا بعائلتك بالاول
وهذا كمان من التقليل القديم اللي قال له
للرسول لانه امي وابوي يعود بعدهم وثنيين
شو بعمل فيهم قال له لا اكراه في الدين
اعطوني المثل الصح
الاطروحات المبسطه
وصلتنا
سريعه وما بنتعمق بالفصول وبنتعمق مثلا بس
هيدا كله كله توابع اقتصاديه اجتماعيه لما
بتسمح باقامه وقف اهلي معناتها عم بتشجع
الناس انها تعطي اموال وتوظف اولادها بس
متلا مثل البعين كمان الاولاد يديروا
الوقت والوقف يستفيد منه جماعه هذا يسمح
باقامه مستشفيات مدارس دور علم كلن
تتشجعوا لانه صار عم بحسوا انه هذا الوقف
يستفيدوا منه بنفس الوقت بينما
الفقه المالكي بقول له لا لما تعطي وقت هو
لوجه الله خلاص ما عاد له حق ابنك يراسه
ما له حق يستفيد منه بتكون عم بتخالف
اوامر الله وهل لذلك لم تطلع على
الاماكن
فيها
الفقه المالكي بتلاقي مستشفيات اقل مدارس
اقل معناتها ما عم بيستفيدوا من عم بيجرد
وبالضبط وعم بيعملوا بالايه التانيه انه
الوقف لوجه الله ما فيك انت تتحكم فيه
لذلك كل هذه الامور الى توابع والتوابع
الاجتماعيه الاقتصاديه لهذا اللي لازم
نتحرها على الاقل على الاقل تصير نفهم
تاريخ هذه الحضاره وما نسلم فيه مثل ما
بيقولنا
المجموعه الان في السعوديه الثانيه اللي
هي سرديه
انحطاط النهضه العربيه
لازم نرجع لانه لا يوقف
السريه الكلاسيكيه اللي بتقول من الاول
بتقول انه في تعارض ما بين الدين والعلم
ليه لانه الخبره تبعهم في اوروبا واللي
كمان مفسره خطا بتقول انه الكنيسه كانت
تحارب العلماء
وبيستشهدوا دائما بهذا الشهير جاليليو انه
قال ليو كان يقول ان هو يدعم الفكر
الكوبرنيكي اللي بيسمح انه الارض مركزيتها
شو اسمه الكون مركزيته ما تكون حول الارض
وانما حول حول الشمس هذا يعارض تعاليم
الكنيسه لذلك حاربوه ولذلك قالوا انه اي
واحد يتعصب للكنيسه يعني يكون متدين بنفس
الوقت هذا عم يتخلى عن العقلانيه
كيف تجعل الاطروحات اللي بيزرعوا هذا
السردين الكلاسيكيه ورطتنا بمشاكل نحن
بغنى عنها مش بس هيك ورطتنا بمشاكل
اجبرتنا انه نعيد تركيبه التاريخ اللي نحن
نعرف يعني مثلا اذا كنت انا بدي صدق انه
الامام الغزالي عبر كتاب احياء علوم الدين
وعبر تهافه الفلاسفه قضى على العلم شو
بعمل بنصير الدين الطوسي اللي بيجي بعد
منه حوالي 200 ووضع نظريات للفرق ونظريات
رياضيه من اجود مقنع شو بعمل بمؤيد الدين
العرضي اللي كمان كان
بمدرسه
وكمان يضع نظريات في الرياضيات حتى تثبت
علم الفلك او تضحك وشو بنعمل بكل الانتاج
مثل ابن الشاطر الدمشقي اللي كان مؤقت
بالجمع الاموي نحن بنعرف الوقت وظيفي دنيا
تقريبا ولكن هذا يتق من من الدين يعني من
مؤسسه الدينيه الجامعه الاموي مش مش مؤسسه
عقلانيه هذا بيشتغل هونيك مؤقت وبنفس
الوقت ياتي بنظريات عن حركات الكوارث ليه
لانه المواققت لازم يعرف
فريضه يعرف اي ساعه وقت الفجر اي ساعه
اقامه صلاه العصر كل هالامور هذه لازم
يعرفها ولازم يهتدي فيها عبر الرياضيات
المعقده واحنا
العلوم الفلك والامور هذا كان بس لما صار
يعرف هذا وصار المواقت الدمشقي يعرف انه
في تغيير هدف خطوط الطول والعرض والامور
هذه الى تبعات صار ساعتها يجيد ويخون لما
يطلع على الفلك اليوناني يقول هذا فيه
هفوات مش بس الحجاج صلح الاخطاء قبل منه
باربعين ستميه سنه
هلا في اخطاء لا يمكن ان تعقل منها بيقول
انه بالفلك اليوناني اذا كنا بدنا نصدق
الفراخ اليوناني بيقول لنا انه وقت القمر
عمرو اسبوع فقط يعني نصف دائره نطلع على
حسب الحسابات او التصورات اليونانيه لازم
القمر يبدي لعينينا وكانه ضعف وقت اللي
بيكون بدر ابن الشاطر ولم يرى كذلك ما
بحياتي شفت القمر وهو ربع يعني الاسبوع
الاول النصف الدائره وتكون هذه الدائره
بهذا الحجم فاذا يجب ان نعيد النظر بالفلك
اليوناني كله وهون ببلش ببناء الفلك
الحديث واللي يستهويه في اكثر
الاطروحه اللي حطها هذا الموقت بالجمع
الاموي بعد منه 200 سنه بيجي كبرنيك
وبيقول نفس الشيء بقول نحن لم نرى القمر
انه يكبر هالقد فا ذا لازم ناخذ النظريه
اللي تسلمها ابن الشاطر عطانا اياها وهذه
النظريه اصبحت هي جزء من الفلك الكوبرنيكي
وصار فيها هذه النقله من العلوم العربيه
الى العلوم
في بعد الغزالي بكم
ابن الشاطر توفي سنه 1375 الغزال توفي
1011 يعني اربعه اربعه
كذلك وعلي ان ابتدع
يعني هو الابتداع هون كيف تعمل نظريات
مستقبليه يعني تقولوا وين راح يكون القمر
بعد كذا لما بتعمل له تنظيم رياضه بس
يرتقدر
هذا ابن الشاطر اللي جاب على هذه الاسئله
بتكوين فلك بديل للفلك اليونان واللي
استهوى
في 1543 ابن الشاطر توفي
1375 قبل 200 سنه تقريبا انت تقول انه بعد
الغزالي
منهاره الحضاره
انتاجها ابن الشاطر انتاج ابن شاطر برهان
اساسي على اي فلك حدث قبل الغزاله بس يمكن
يكون هذا يتيم واحد في غير
لما تفتح الباب هتلاقي دار
الغزالي شو اسمه ابن الشاطر
خطم الطريق لانه قبل ابن الشاطئ كان فينا
يصير الدين الطوسي اللي كتب رساله مهمه
جدا سماها
[موسيقى]
ومنها مثلا اللي كتبوا نصير الدين الطوسي
رساله في الهيئه والفصل الثالث عشر فيها
الاشكالات التي وردت في الفلك اليوناني
والاجوبه عليها بالاجوبه عليها
يسبق ذلك هو عم يوصف كان اليوناني كيف كان
بيكتبوا وعم بيقول انه الفلك اليوناني
يفترض انه في الحركات الكواكب بالعرض تحدث
كذا شو بقول عبد نصير الدين بيقول انا
اقول هذا كلام خارج عن الصناعه يعني اللي
بيتحدث في حديث من انه ما بيعرف فلك وعم
مين عم ينتقل عم ينتقد اكبر فلكيه اليونان
اللي هو بطلميون وخارج عن الصناعه بيقول
لانه اذا كنا بدنا ناخذ الفلك الجني على
علاته معناتها راح يصير في حركات اللي
بيسميها حركات بالكواكب لسميهم وارجحه هذه
لا يجوز ان نكون ولكن كل الحركات لازم تضل
دائريه وبنفس الوقت تضل على خط مستقيم
لذلك استحدث عن النظريه الفلكيه اللي نحن
هلا
نوم الهي مز
اذا بتاخد دائرتين او
فلكين واحد ضعف الثاني
حجما وبتحط الصغرى تنتقل من اليمين الى
الشمال والكبرى تنتقل من الشمال الى
اليمين
وتناسب بالسرعتين ينتج عنهم نقطه التلاقي
على خط المستقيم هذا الخط المستقيم هذا
الذي نطبقه بالميك الان لما تاخذ السياره
وتمشيها هذه السياره تعمل على هذا
البيستون اللي هو يتحرك بشكل
قائم وهذا يسمح بتواصل هذا تواصل هذه
الحركه بالحركه الدائريه توصل هذه الحركه
بحركه دواليب وهكذا السياره كليات يعتمد
على هذه النظريه التي اكتشفها ناصر الدين
الطوزي وهذا اتى بعد الغزالي بحوالي 200
سنه طيب شو بعمل فيه هذا بقول انه هذا
جاهل لانه اجا وراء الغساله الغزالي
وبعدين
صار يجي تعليقات على الطوسي يعني مثلا شرح
مذكره تذكره الطوسي يجي شرح على الشرح
كمان اللي كتب عنه
هو الجرجاني وكمان اللي
الى ان نصل الى القناه الثالث عشر
الفلكي الشهير
لان اكن له كل احترام وكتبت كتاب مخصص له
اللي سميتها
معالم الاصاله والابداع
في الشروحات
والنظريه الفلكيه المتاخره وسميتها بعد
نقطتين اعمال
فخر الدين له اعمال شمس الدين الخفري التي
توفي سنه 1550 ميلادي واللي هو معاصر هذا
لحل كل الامور اللي كانت متوارثه من الفلك
اليوناني
والاعتراضات
ابن الهيثم والجوابات اللي جاب فيها
النصير الدين كل هذا بيقول انه ورطنا
بمشاكل ما قدرتوا تحلوها لذلك هو هذا شمس
الدين الخاطري بيقول انا ساضع كتاب وضعه
سماه حل كل ما لا ينحل كل المشاكل الفلكيه
اللي تورطتوا فيها هذا الحل تبعها واعطانا
النتائج والنتائج من اجود اعمال الرياضيات
اللي ممكن الواحد يتعرض
بتفسير الحركات الفلكيه بشكل رياضي ممتاز
والمحافظه على الكوزمولوجيه الاساسيه اللي
بتقول انه الفلك كله يدور وكل الافلاك
تدور حول مركز الثقل مركز الثقل هو الارض
لذلك
اعتقد انه مثل ما قال لازم ننقله للشمس
بقى يتكلم على الارض وهذه الحركات وهذا
كله تحدث الغزالي طيب شو بعمل فيهم بعملهم
لانه بقول الغزاله قتل العلوم
خلي المخطوطات تبعه اللي موجوده بالتقريب
من كل مكتبات العالم بحطها بالجرار بطل
اطلع عليه فاذا شو بعمل بالشريفه جرجاني
شو بعمل بيه شمس الدين الخفري شو بعمل
بقطب الدين الشيرازي شو بعمل بمؤيد الدين
العرضي كلها بده يجوا من بعد الغزاله
وكتبوا فلك من اجود ما خلق الله فاذا لم
يكن عصر الانحطاط ما بعد الغزال اي في
القريه
النسمه المج لازم تكون للغزالي انا بقول
لك انه حصل انحطاط عالمي انحطاط علمي وانا
مش سباق لا لا عادي اللي كشف هذه النظريين
او هذا التحليل انه لا
الاقتصاد تحرك بطريقه
والحياه الاجتماعيه تحركت بطريقه هو
المؤرخ في
الاقتصاد اللي اسمه ادم سميث ادم سميث
وقت اللي عم بيكتب سنه 1771 او 75 ايام
الثوره الامريكيه لعلمت العالم
اللي علمت انه شعوبه بطرر هذا عم بيكتب
بهديك الفتره وبيقول اذا استحدثنا اطلعنا
على الاطار الاجتماعي
والاقتصادي للعالم نرى انه في حدثين مهمين
كتير اللي حدثوا اولا اكتشاف امريكا
تانيين اكتشاف الطريق حول القاره
الافريقيه تنوصل للشرق
بيقول لما تحرك
اكتشفوا امريكا حركه الاقتصاد كلها
تغيرت من الاتجاه الى الشرق عبر
الاراضي
والاوطان كلها تقريبا
بالاسلام الى
الحضاره الاتجاه نحو الغرب الى ان يصلوا
اللي اعتقد في هذا
اعتبر انه وصل الى الهند لما وصل لامريكا
الاسبانيولا اتطلب العالم قال له انتم
هنود ولكن مبين عنكم حمر
هنود حمر مسكين هم سكان البلد الاصليين
يعني هذه الاخطاء التاريخيه
اخطاء كولومبوس مش عارف وين رايح او نحسب
انه الارض اصغر ومحسب راح يوصل للهند
والصين باسرع من الوقت ولكن ارتطم به
اسبانيولا اللي هي بامريكا الوسطى
الاقتصاديه حولت خطوط التجاره لهذا مش مثل
ترجمه بعدين فسر لنا اياها انه تحويل
التجاره له توابع شو التوابع اذا توقف
التجاره بتوقف الاموال اذا ما في ما في
تجاره ما في ضرائب اذا ما في ضرائب ما في
اموال معناتها كل الحركه الاقتصاديه
انتقلت من عبر المدن
والبلدان الاسلاميه الى البلدان اللي هو
سماها الهنود الحمر اللي هن امريكا
والتفوا حوله
بافريقيا ووصلوا الى الهند واستغنوا عن كل
المساحات الشاسعه اللي كانت تتحكم فيها
الحضاره الاسلاميه هذا انا هذا التحول له
اسباب تدهور اقتصادي يعني لما بتحول
التجاره لمحل ثاني العالم اللي كانت على
الخط خط تجاره الحرير
لما بتفتقر ما بقعد فيك تدعم مؤسسات علميه
ما ببعد فيك تدفع مدارس ما بقعد في كل
التوابع الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه فلذلك انا
بقول لازم ننتظر
للقرن السادس عشر من بعد ما اكتشفت ونوافق
مع عدم سميث انه النقل الاقتصادي اللي
صارت هي اللي سببت الركود في العلم مش
لانه الغزاله هذا عم بعطيك الشواهد ست سبع
علماء فلك كتبوا من بعض الغزالي من اجود
ما كتب ومنهم شمس الدين الخفري اجود خلق
الله هودي ما سببهن التدهور فاذا التدهور
لازم نبحث عنه
بنقله التجاره ونقلت سير التجاره وننتقل
الى هلا الان يستحدث عبر الصين عم بستخدم
طريق الحرير الحديثي
عن طريق الحرير اللي كانت مصدر اموال كل
هذه
المساحات الشاشه من اقاصي الصين من بلاد
الله ياجوج وماجوج الى الاسكندريه والى
متوسط كانوا يعتاشوا من هذه التجاره هلا
افتقدت انا بقول لازم شو صاير بالقرن
الخامس عشر مش شو صار بالغزالي شو صار
بالقرن غانم من تحركات اقتصاديه اللي سببت
ركود باي مؤسسه ولم تحدث بسبب الاسلام
لانه حدث نفس الظاهره من بعض القرن الخامس
عشر حدثت
بالشبه القاره الهنديه العلوم الهنديه
كانت منافسه للعلوم الاسلاميه ولا العلوم
الاوروبيه بالقرن الخامس عشر
كمان العلوم الصينيه الصين كمان كان عندهم
علوم عريقه بس في القانون الخامس عشر لما
تحول كل الاقتصاد وتحولت التجاره بهذا
الشكل كل صار ما عندهم غزاله الله يرضى
عليهم يعني ليش حدا يوقف ما منلاقي عند
الصين او عند الهند حتى يسبب الركود فاذا
هذا التفسير تبع النسبه الى الغزل هو تعصب
اعمى للناس يعرفوا انه بس اقرا علاقه
العلم بالكنيسه عندما تتدهور يتدهور
الباقه واللي جايبين هذا المقياس معهم من
اوروبا ومن علاقه جاليليو بالكنيسه
الكاثوليكيه كل هذا هراء لازم نرجع نتطلع
على الامور الواقعيه الامور اللي بنعرف
تاريخها اللي بنعرف عنها كيف صارت حركات
التجاره كليتنا نعرف ما بظن انه في انسان
ما بيعرف اذا توقفت التجاره توقفت
لاستدرار الاموال عندما تستغر الاموال
لتتوقف الاموال يتوقف الدعم
الفكري او الدعم الصناعي كل الامور هذه هي
اللي تسبب الانحدار طيب وش اسباب نهضه
اوروبا اذا هذا لان الشيء الوحيد اللي
عملوه باوروبا واللي هو منتهى الذكاء لما
وصلوا لامريكا واكتشفوا من السكان
المحليين
بهسبانيولا اكتشفوا انه عمل للرجال
والنساء يتحلوا بالذهب قال له هذا الذهب
يعني تجيب بهارات وهذا البهارات مفيده
لاوروبا لانه لحم اذا تركته يومين ثلاثه
لازم تحط
قالولو من النهر هون دلوني عليها وهناك
بدات الاموال اللي استثمروها من الذهب
اللي اكتشفوه في القاره الجديده بامريكا
وهذا الذهب ما اجى للبلدان الاسلاميه رجع
لاوروبا اوروبا ما كبته
وتتباهى فيه بسيارات جديد وما صارت تغني
معامل السيارات وتصرف الاموال عليها وتهدر
استعملته لانشاء مؤسسات يعني لاول مره
بالتاريخ
ينشا مؤسسات اهتمامه فقط بحث العلمي مثلا
المؤسسه اللي صارت اللي سموه باللاتيني
اكاديميه
كروسكا اللي هذه كمان بلشت وبعدين قبلها
كمان اجت الاكاديميه تاني بايطاليا
عم تيجي هلق عبر الذهب والفضه اللي
اكتشفناه هالاموال هادي ما بيجوز انه
نصرفها رائع لازم على الاقل نستثمر فيها
لننتج منها
الاكاديميات العلميه كمان مش عجيب ان كل
تكون
بالممالك الاوروبيه ما بين 1550 يعني بعد
اكتشف اوروبا ما كان في اكاديميات علميه
قبل من 1550 للالف وستميه هلا بعدين صار
كل بلد باوروبا عنده اكاديميه الملكيه
لكذا الاكاديمي ومنها الاكاديميه
الانجليزيه
كمان صار يدلبوا حتى
الاخواننا اللي هن
بهولندا اللي بعثوا كمان
رحلات استكشافيه لما نسميه اليوم زميلنا
اللي جابنا من اندونيسيا ليكون معه خير
حولي كمان استعملتهم بالاول هولندا وهوندي
يستثمروا هذه التجاره الجديده واغنوا فيها
شمال اوروبا هذا هو الجزء التاريخي
الحقيقي اللي لازم نعرفهم انه بدون دعم
المؤسسات العلميه تموت لازم يضل في دعم
مستمر وهذا الدعم ليؤمن بناء الجيل التالي
لانه اذا هلا واحد منا توقف عن الابحاث
العلميه مين بدو يورثنا اذا ما ربينا نشا
طالع جديد ونعلمهم كيف يطلعوا على تاريخهم
معناته نحن عم نساوي عم نساهم بهذا
الانحدار اللي بعده كان الانحدار هو ما
بعد القانون السادس عشر هو جزء من لا
يتجزا عن الحمل اللي حولت اوروبا مما يسمى
يعني بالغالب 1500 لالفه ستميه كان يقولوا
انه هذا سيطره العقل لا لانه بدنا نضحك
الكنيسه ونسب عليها ونعمل كله ونشات
الحركات الدينيه مثل حركه البروستنطينيه
وكلنا عوده على اساس حرب قائمه باوروبا
ونقتدي بالمثال اللي صار باوروبا ونطبقه
على باقي العالم لا في عالم مثل ابن الشر
كان يعيش مع المؤسسه الدينيه بكل خير ما
عنده مشكله كانت كمان المؤسسات الثانيه من
النفيس كان بنفس الوقت طبيب ويعلق على
الطب وده وكمان نفس الوقت يعلم بالمدرسه
فقهيه كل هذا
معناتها لما بناخذ مقياس واحد ومنطبقه على
اوروبا وانا مش متاكد انه يصح حتى باوروبا
لانه بظن الحركات اللي صارت بقلب اوروبا
ما لها علاقه كثير بموقف قال لي من
فلك كبرنيه صار لها كمان علاقات اقتصاديه
صار لها تحولات اقتصاديه وفي البلدان اللي
سابقت واكتشفت الذهب والفضه
في منه استفادوا منه بس في منه مع انه
جابوا الذهب اسبانيا هلا تقريبا
من افقر البلدان الاوروبيه مع انه هي كانت
البوابه
لكل الذهب والفضه اللي اجا من امريكا
اللاتينيه ومن
المكسيك كانت تستعمل بيسموها اسبانيا
الجديد وش السبب برايك ليش اسبانيا هي
اللي
رغم انها كانت البوابه
هذه بدا يعني
ما بتنطح على امور ما بعرفها
التاريخ اسبانيا وعلاقتها بالدوره
الاقتصاديه اللي صارت فيها
شيء مختلف عن اللي صار بالاكاديميات
العلميه الباقي يعني وكمان في دور ثالث
الاشياء مهمه
اللي انا بوضع بدي اكتب كتاب عنه انه كمان
تحويل العلم اللي حدث في اوروبا تحويل
العلم من الغايه المعرفيه الى الغايه
الاستثماريه يعني صرت تعمل علوم مش لزياده
المعرفه بالعلوم صرت تعمل علوم يستفيد
منها السوء يستفيد منها الحركه التجاريه
ولذلك بكل المؤسسات الحديثه من الادويه من
الطب من كل المقدسه شو اسمه المؤسسه
الكبرى في عندهم
قسم كبير من هالمؤسسات بسموها
شو يعني ديفال يعني في عندك ناس تنصرف فقط
لدراسه
المستحدثات العلميه اللي بتطلع وتطبيقها
على اللي بيجي عبر التداول التجاري كل هذا
هو اللي بيستحدث علم جديد للحضاره العربيه
كانت تعرفه ولا الحضارات البائيه واوروبا
البلد
تجمع الوحيد اللي استثمر هذه الامور
واخترع شيء جديد لم يكن موجود بالعالم قبل
هو استحداث ما يسمى براءات واغلى
الاختراعات براءه
الاختراع يعني
شو هذا يعني تعطي لصاحب المعرفه اللي
تعطيه حصريا استثمار هذه المعرفة انه هو
يحول من معرفه لاجل المعرفه الى استثمار
هذا العلم للاسباب التجاريه وهذه البراءه
تاتي على عده اشكال واحد منها انه تسمح
لهم بالاحتكار يعني مثلا سنه 1650
اخترعوا شيء جديد اسمه
يعني شركه تجاريه اعطوها حصريا حق التعامل
التجاري مع الهند بعد ما اكتشفوا الهند
هذه
حق الانتفاع الحصري للشركات معينه
اضاف وافاد هل اثر ايجابي على الحضاره
الغربيه ولا كانسل بي لان ريحه في الاسلام
فيها تحفيز يعني بتعطي اي واحد
تحفيز انه بتحدث اشياء جديده بتلاقي مفك
براغي جديد بتستفيد منه
هذا يشجع العالم ان يخلع ولكن عندما تصل
الى انك تحرم بقيه الانسانيه منه وبقيت
المجتمع منه بصير شر وبعرف انه نحن كمان
لازم نهتدي بالتاريخ والتاريخ بالنا انه
الفيل حديث الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام
بيقولنا من علم علما
وظنا به على اخيه المؤمنه جاء يوم القيامه
ملجما من نار شو معناها معناها اذا انت
بتعرف شيء وما استفادت منه الامه وما
استفادت منه الجماعه واحتكرت فقط
المقوله الثانيه الاحتقار
من احتكر كفر كمان معناته في عنا قيم
اخلاقيه بعدنا متمسكين بها ما طلعنا من
فوقه بينما الحضاره الاوروبيه تفوقت عليها
وصارت
لانه
كل هذه القيم الكنسيه
والقيم الدينيه لازم نتخطاها ونفذ من فوقه
تنوصل على المكاسب الماديه لما تحول
التفكير الانساني والحياه الانسانيه الى
مكاسب
ميدانيه
مكاسب تجاريه تحول كل دور العلم وكل دور
الله ليه بنبحث عن المعرفه وشو قيمه
المعرفه اذا ما فينا نسوقها ونبيعها
بالسوسر السوق يتحكم بالعلم
لذلك انه انا بعرف عندي جميل بكولومبيا
كليه الحقوق
كتب كتاب اسمه
في شركات ادويه
عندهم دواء
لمعالجه
او معالجه السرطان ولكن حتى يعمموا هذا
الدواء لازم يشتروا البراءات او حقوق
البراءات الباقيين اخذينها وكل ذره كل
خليه بالجسم الانساني مسجله تحت براءه
معينه يعني تيقول حتى هذا الدواء يقدروا
بندفعوا الاف والاف من الدولارات حتى يصير
يجربوا هذا الدواء
هذا بصير معهد محفز لانتاج صار هلا نيه
مؤخر صارت انت معك بيترك الدواء بيقول انه
الدواء بعده لا يزال على الرفوف ما حدا
بيستعمله ليه لانه الاقتصاد وصل لكريد لوك
شوك يعني اذا بتكثر هالادنيه من تحكم
بالبراءات ما بقعد في انتاج بتصير النتيجه
عكسيه انا بقول انه معه حق كليا لازم نفكر
بكل هذه الامور هنا تروى قبل ما نقول يلا
بنعطي جوائز للي اولا ايه منيحه بتحفزه
والعالم ده ولكن لازم ان تضبط هذه الامور
ما تكون تترك على علاتها لازم تكون تستفيد
منها المجتمع اللي يعلم وادرس واعترف
اموال لهذا العالم تروح على المدرسه تروح
على الوقفيه تروح يشتري الكتب تاهله
يقدروا يعيشوه كل هذا المصاريف ما حدا
بيحسبها
بينحسبوا بالاخر وان اجا عشان الارباح
تعتقد اليوم انه الشركات اللي تصرف على
الابحاث والتطوير
المليارات لغرض يعني واضح ان اغراضهم ليس
المعرفه بحد ذاته وانما غرضهم بيع منتجات
للسوق انه ساهم في ازدهار الحضاره الغربيه
والعلم عند الغرب ما في شك
اي محل تشرف فيه اموال لتشجيع مؤسسات
ياتي بارباح وهذه الارباح انا لن ما اظن
انه لازم نستهجئ بها ولكن يجب هذه الارباح
ان لا تتحكم بمصير شعوب يعني امم باسرع
تصير مستعمره فقط لانه بيطلع فيها شجر
نرجيله منطق الدرجين صارت بس حتى تطلع شاي
لاهل يعني هل
وضع الامور باطار الانسان
والاخلاقيه الانسانيين لازم تتحكم بهذه
الامور
مهم جدا مع انه اذا كان عم نتطلع على راس
مال
ينصب ويطلب فقط زياده المال اذا كان
الغايه فقط زياده المال معناه لم نحمل
اولادنا ما منعودنا على ما يعودوا يعرفوا
شو هيدا قواعد شيبوين ما يعودوا يعرفوا
هذا الفقه الحنفي منه لانه شعر نستفيد منه
والطلاب هيك عم بيقولوا لنا انه عم
بيقولوا لهم روح عموله مهندس او معمول
حكيم حتى تجني من الربح معناته صرنا نوجه
طلابنا حتى ما يروحوا للحقيقه كما هي حتى
زياده المعرفه اللي اجت زياده المعرفه هو
عم بتوجهوا الى زياده الكشف فلذلك بتلاقي
في دفق عام على الكليات الهندسه وكليات
الطب لدرجه صعب تودي ابنك على كليه طب هلا
يمكن الحدث توصلها ليه لانه كل جدنا ننتظر
منا الربح بالاخر وانه معاش الطبيب يكفي
اكثر من المهتم مثلا بكنه الوقف الاهلي
انفع من الوقف العام او لا هذا الامور
اللي فيها درس للاخلاقيات انه كيف الانسان
لازم يتعامل مع نعم الرب لما الرب بيسمح
لك تاخذ من ثروتك قسم من هذه الثروه
وتحطوا لخدمه
وبنفس الوقت تسمح لعائلتك انها تستفيد منه
صار هذا الوقف اله معاني وهذه المعاني هي
الحركه الاقتصاديه هاي الحركه اقتصاديه هي
تشجع هاي او تهمل اذا كل هذه الامور معقده
لدرجه انه لا يجب ان نستخف بها ونقول انه
على بركه الله الله يبعث هذا منيح ما هو
الله راح يبعد بس طلب منك انه تقوم للصلاه
على الاقل انك تعمل واجباتك قبل ما تقوم
طيب بدي اعرف الحين
اثر الاستعمار على الحضاره العربيه
والاسلاميه او على
المعرفه وازدهاره في المنطقه العربيه
والمنطقه اثر الواضح انك تحدثت عنه قبل
شوي هو الاستعمار قال للمستعمرين
انتم استقيلوا استريح ونحن بنتفكر عنكم
وهذا في مقوله للفرنش فنون مشهوره جدا
بيقول انه الاستعمار مش دائما ينجح لانه
المستعمر مرات يثور ما فيش كلن بخدعوا
للعالم يعني بيعملوا ثوره وهذه ثوره يعني
فيها ممانعه
ولكن ينجح الاستعمار عندما المستعمر
يتخلق باخلاقيه المستعمر يعني لما نحن
بنصير نقول مثل ما بيقولوا مثلا
بالمقول الشائعه كل شيء فرنجي برنجي شو
يعني برنجي والتعبير الفارسي تيقولوا انه
هذا احسن البضاعه لازم تيجي من الفرنج
يعني لازم تيجي من محل غائب عنا نحن ما
بنعرفه وهذا معناتها تاليه ونوع من
التقدير الزائد للمستعمر للمستعمر هو اللي
بيستفيد من مقولات من هالنوع اما الشعب
المستعمر بضل ينوه تحت العذاب ويتالم
وبنفس الوقت ما حدا بيكلم انينو
هذا التاثير الواضح يعني تاثير الواضح وقت
اللي نحن بتتغير اخلاقيتنا ومنصير ننظر
للمجتمع وانه هو يدين لنا بشيء انا طبيب
بدي اخذ مصاري قد ما بقدر اطلع مصاري
ارحموا الناس يعني كون اقل متواضعين
اشكروا ربكم انه وصلتوا هذه الاخلاقيه
يشكر ربها تواضع كل هذه الامور اللي هي
اخلاقيه من التربيه البيتيه تاخذها من
تربيه الدينيه اللي انت بتؤمن فيها بغض
النظر عن اي دين ولكن لما بتتخطى الامور
وبتصير استغلال الانسان الثاني بغض النظر
كانه شرقي او غربي او شو ما كان لما تبلش
باستغلال الناس وتستعمل الناس كهمه
اليه تطلع في الاموال اللي انا بسميه
الراسماليه المتكالبه لما توصل لهذا
المستوى ما عاد في انسانيه بنكون خسرنا
الجزء الانساني المهم بالمجتمعات طيب
اليوم لم تعد في اي دوله عربيه مستعمره ما
عدا يعني واحده
ومع ذلك لا يزال معظم
كل الدول العربيه لا تزال يعني طلعت من
الاستعمار لكنها لا تزال
متاخره جدا علميا
لانه كمان الاستعمار مش شوكي بتشيلها
ويشفوا الجسم
الاستعمار يترك خلفيه
وهذا الخلفيه الاخلاقيه تاخذ اجيال حتى
تقدر تتخطاها وتحول تفكير
المستعمر تحولوا انه يفكر بابداعيته هو
انه نحن مش عاجزين فينا ننتج بدون ما يكون
الدافع الاساسي هو الاموال الاموال عاليه
اذا اتت اهلا وسهلا بها ولكن لا نشرف كل
جهدنا لاستدرار الاموال هذا بظن انه مهم
مضبوط بتقول انه
بنعرفها لاني اخذت استقلالها بس معجم
من عشر سنين 15 سنه خصوصي هون منطق تاخد
اجيال حتى تبني الشخصيه الاستقلاليه
الذاتيه الحق
بتضلك تقلد الغرب بعدنا بنقول انه الفرنجي
برنجي الى الان مع انه ما عاد في فرنج
الفرنج انتحوا وراحوا والفرنجي يطلق على
ايام الصليبيين يعني القرن الثاني عشر او
الحالي عشر مع انه موجه
بس بعدنا نحن بالتقليد تعبيري بنقول
الفرنجي برنجي
واي شيء مثلا بيقول هذا يكتب مقالات في
مجلات محكمه او تصدر فيه اوروبا وجمانيا
اما الباقي هذا يكتب مقالات بالعربي ما
حدا بيقرح ما بيحترموها بنفس
تتخلقنا باخلاقيات المستعمره مثل ما قال
تتدهور الحضاره عندما تتبنى افكار
الاستعمار وتصبح حين الافكار السائده بين
العالم
كليا بالنسبه لاستخدام اليوم معظم الدول
العربيه
[موسيقى]
تستخدم في تعليمها سواء في الجامعي او
بعضها حتى في مادون الجامعي اللغه غير
العربيه سواء انجليزي ولا غيرها في عبد
الرحمن سليمان هو استاذ لغات واداب ساميه
يقول اخراج اللغه العربيه من تدريس العلوم
والطب خاصه
لا يؤدي فقط الى تخريج اطباء لا يعرفون
معبودا غير المال قبل شوي بل يؤدي الى
تراجع ممنهج لملكه التفكير العلمي عند
العرب وبالتالي الى تاخر اللغه العربيه عن
مواكبه التطور العلمي والى عجز العرب عن
اللحاق بركب الحضاره مين اللي قال هذا عبد
الرحمن السليمان السليمي سليمان سليمان
انا ما بعرف اعماله ولكن عنا خبره وانا
مسن جيادي بعرف انه لما صار في استقلال
لبنان وسوريا عن الانتداب الفرنسي لبنان
تهافت انه يعلم الاولاد كل اللغات يعني
الطالب بلبنان بيحكي فرنسي انجليزي وعربي
لا يتقن اي منها يعني الاتقان شيء
والتعليم يعني بتتعلم اللغه للاستخدام
التجاري كمان وبيصير يقول بلبنان كانو
الشركات يقولوا انه حسن البيروت على باقي
البلدان العربيه انه ببيروت تقدر تحط
اعلان الصبح بدي سكرتيره تحكي فرنسي
وانجليزي بيجيك الاجوبه بعد الظهر بيجيك
الطلبات انه ليله انه عنا التدريب موجود
بالمدارس تبعنا بس هذا على ثمن معناتها ما
بتلاقي بقى هلا ببيروت اللي بتتقن كل
اللغات حدا يعرف مثلا انه يعجبني في
الذكريات سخاؤها اللي باخر مباراه تعملوها
هلا نيه
الشعراء والشاعر الليبي اللي قال له انه
هذا شاعر ممتاز واللي هو تفوه فيها
ويعجبني في الذكريات سخاؤ
معترض على رئيس اللجنه اللي عنده
الدكتوراه واللي اخذ غضب مقارنه وعمل كل
شيء
لازم تفكر فيها وترجع وتعتذر قال له لا
انتم ما تعتذروا اللجنه انتظروا انا عم
بحكي العربي الصحيح معه لما ما بيقعد عندك
ملكه اللغه فتعرف كانه سخاؤوها او سخائها
وبتصير بس تنبهر بالشهادات من هون
ومشاهدات من هناك ومعظمها لازم تكون
جامعات اجنبيه
من جامعه عربيه معناتها اقل احترام
معناتها هيدي اثر الاستعمار هذا هو
التدهور المستمر هذا هو الانقراض اللي نحن
عم نعيشه هلا ويستمر بهذا الشكل الى ان
نستعيد يوما ما ان شاء الله الثقه بالنفس
انه نحن يمكن ان نبدع مثل ما ابدع
واجدادنا اللي انا كتبت عنهم واللي سميته
معالم اصاله والابداع في الشروحات ان اللي
كنا بنعملها من هنا لشرح ما بيفيدنا زي ما
بيفيدنا بس بنلاقي معظم النظريات الجديده
عم ترد بشروحات ولاسباب وانا بفندها بهذا
الكتاب معناه هذا لازم نرجع نستعيد هذه
الثقه انه
الانسان العربي مبدع في امكانيه انه يبدع
اشياء جديده بس لازم ناهله ونعطيه الدعم
المادي اللي هو بدرجه الاولى بدون
استمراريه
عم تعمل ماده
تنقرض كل المؤسسات اي مؤسسه بتعرف مهما
كانت فريقي اذا بتعملها لجيل واحد تنتهي
بجيل واحد بدك تبني فيها
الاستمراريه
والاستمراريه تاتي من التخطيط للمستقبل
في نفس الوقت اليوم يعني اذا بدي اعرف ايش
اللي ناقص اذا الدم المادي انا ما اعرف عن
كل الدول السعوديه
فاعتقد واعتقد كثير من الدول العربيه نفس
الشيء او حتى الخليجيه بالتحديد ثلث
الميزانيه او حتى بعضها ربع الميزانيه
العامه للدوله تصرف على التعليم
فالميزانيات الضخمه تصرف التعليم يعني في
السعوديه ظاهر هناك اكثر من يعني يمكن
خمسين كليه 30 جامعه بس لا يزال
وين احنا اكاديميا من العالم بعيدين تماما
يعني في فارق كبير لازم ناخذ العبره انه
ما نصرفه لا يكفي يعني لازم نزيد نزيد
الدعم حتى نؤسس لاجيال القادمه حتى وهذه
التكلفه ما بتبين مش كل العالم بتشوف انك
لم تضرب على المساري على المدارس وبتصرف
على الجامعات وبتطرف على المختبرات وكل
هذا ما بتجيب اموال بكره الصبح
بتاخد بتاخذ جيل حتى يعني اوروبا لمن بدات
اول اكاديميات
العلميه اللي بدات باوروبا بدات تون من
بعد اكتشاف امريكا لانه صار عندهم ذهب
وعندهم فضه صار في اموال بس صرفوا الاموال
باستثمارها للمستقبل هذه الاكاديميات هلا
عم نشوف حصادها
اتذكر في وحده من المحاضراتك كنت تقول انه
لا نركز على ركود او انحطاط العالم العربي
او الحضاره العربيه
خلونا نركز على ليش هم
كيف قدروا انهم ينهضون عشان نعرف كيف نقدر
ناخذ بنودي بنفس المقياس مو بدي اركز يمكن
يعرف ليش احنا في العالم العربي
يعني صرنا غيرنا
فكره العلماء من انهم علماء في العلم
التجريبي الى علماء
بالشكل الديني فلما تجي تقول انت اليوم
العلماء ما يحضر في ذهنك يعني بالنسبه لي
لما اقول العلماء يحضر في بالي على طول
اللي هم علماء الدين ما يحضر ببالي علماء
غير الدين
لانك مش عم تتسمى على الله يرحمه
الايمان بن تيميه اللي كتب كتاب من اهم
الكتب اللي انا بظنه
ما من غمض على انه ابن تيميه عن بالي من
الدرجه الاولى وهو استاذ بالفقه هو كل
ولكن كتب كتاب شهير جدا بس مش كل العالم
تعرفه كتب كتاب سماه درع
التعارض بين العقل والنقل انه لازم نطلع
على الرسائل السماويه اللي وصلتنا عبر
الانبياء وعبر المعلمين هذه الرسائل تفترض
وتتطلب منا ان يكون ان عقم لنفهم مغزاهه
اذا ما استخدمنا هذا هل الفصل اللي عم
تحكي عنه في علماء دين علماء تجربيين هذا
ابن تميم لا يا جماعه لازم هذا العقل
الانساني اذا ما شغلناه بنكون عم نخسر اهم
عطيه عطانا اياها الله
الفرق ما بين او التمييز ما بين علماء
الدين
والعلماء التجريبيين شو ما سميتها
كل هذا
كانوا بعده لا يزال من الارث الموديل
الاوروبي يعني النموذج الاوروبي اللي قال
انه مدام انتشرت الكنيسه ما تقلي ليوم طلع
قال ليو ماتت الكنيسه هذا التناقض هذا غير
دقيق وانا بقول عنه قال لي لا
العالم لازم تعرف انه قال لي لا معظم علوم
من مؤسسات التزويد يعني منح الكنيسه
هو اللي ابتدع الاشياء التانيه ولكن تدرب
على هذه
لذلك ما لازم نعول كتير على هذه الفاروق
مثل ما قلنا ابن تيميه انه لازم نبعد هذا
التناقض مش موجود لانه العقل الانساني
يحمل كل الرب اعطانا اياه لازم نستعمله
فهل في فرق بين تعريف العلم عند العرب
وعند المسلمين عن تعريف العلم عند الغرب
يعني لانك لما تقرا اليوم مثلا في تعريف
العلم او مثلا في صفحه ويكيبيديا
في العلوم فتلقاهم يحطون التاريخ والفن
والفلسفه في باب غير العلوم فهي خارج
ما فيش هل هذا يختلف
في اختلافات بعلب الجامعه نفسها
تلاقي حتى بكليات الهندسه مؤخرا صاروا
يفصلوا الشيء اللي سموه هل نيه الهندسه عن
صاروا يسموا
انه ترسم بنايه بس انت بتحط الاشكال اللي
بتحبها هلا بتروح للمهندس ما شاء مرات
بقول لك هذه الاشكال ما يمكن لانه ما في
ماده بتقدر تعمل لك هالاشكال هذه التلاشق
ما بين النواحي الفنيه
المجالات التجريبيه العلميه لهذا هذا مع
الاسف
يعني كل المؤسسات العلميه والاكاديميه
لهذا تنطلق كمان من منطلق مين عم بيدفعوا
يمول هذه المؤسسه رجعنا الى
تفترض تفوق المادي عن الشركه والربح
الماده تفتقر الى المعلومات دي وعنا امثله
عديده يعني الصراع اللي قام بين شركه ابل
وشركه مايكروسوفت تقريبا
عذبتني يعني راحوا اثنين
صارت ابل هلا تنتج تليفونات توقفوا تقريبا
عن انتاج الحاسوب وصارت مايكروسوفت تنتج
اشياء يعني هذا التنفس مرات مفيد مرات في
له تبعات لازم نتعقب الامور حلوه لازم اي
ناس اللي عندهم قدر دول يتحمل لازم هم
يتحملوا المسؤوليه هذه وشوفوا ويكون عندهم
على الاقل منظار للمستقبل يبنوا الاجيال
الجاي
انا عطلت عليك اخر سؤال انا ممنونك جدا
جدا وكنت على الاقل وكانه كانه عم بتسهل
الامور انا ممنونه
السؤال الاخير هو
اليوم هل باقي فيه علوم او حضاره غربيه
وحضاره شرقيه هل باقي في علوم
يعني هذه علوم غربيه وعلوم غير غربيه او
عربيه او شرقيه او صينيه ولا خلاص اليوم
اصبح العالم كله مع بعض والصيني يشارك في
العلوم الامريكيه والامريكيه فما في مهمه
تحاول ان تبني حاضر ما بين حضاره والاخرى
هذا الحائط سياتي احد
مهما يمكن مثلا
وحتى اللي بيحاولوا يعاقبوا ناس مثل الصين
لانه بياخذوا انتاج
الامريكي او غربي ويعيدوا تفكيكم من جديد
واعاده صياغته وهيدي كمان انا بعتبرها نوع
من الثوره على
السلطه البراءات يعني لما بتحط براءه
وتكسب منها
ولا تعوض عنها على المجتمع اللي انت جاني
معناتها كمان انت عم بعجرم الناس الى
الاستفاده منها الغير مشروعه وهذه اي
مشروعها واي هي مش مشروع في النقاش في
نقاش طويل عريض وما لازم نستسلم يعني
اليابان لما نشات بعض الحرب العالميه
الثانيه معظم الانتاج الياباني كان هو
تفكيك الاشياء اللي موجوده اعاده تركيبه
يعني تفكك فتعرف كيف مركبه معجم اول
طيارات مسيره
بتتذكر انه بايران نزلوا واحده من
الطيارات الامريكيه وفككوها هلا ايران
تصدر طائرات روسيه معناتها كل هذه الحواجز
اللي بتعملها بين الحضارات وبين انتقال
العلوم
والبراءات وكل هذه الحواجز مصطنعه وهذه
الحواجز في ناس تتحكم فيها لاسباب الارباح
او الاسباب السيطره السياسيه او كل هذه
الامور انا بجنن الانسان راح يتعاطى مع
المعرفه اينما كانت مثل ما عمل الايام
الدوله الايام عبد الملك وقال له خالد بن
يجد قال له ما تخاف علي نحن نستحدث دينار
جديد والدينار الجديد موجود
معناته اذا عندك هذه الثقه بالنفس انك انت
يمكن ان تنتج لا تنتظر العطاء من حدا ثاني
وانا بظن انه كل الحواجز اللي بتعملها
حيلاقي الانسان يلاقي طريقه يتخطى هذه
الحواجز اذا كانت فقط للربح المادي اذا
كان في دفع
للافاده للمجتمع انا لازم نتظافر ونساعد
اذا كان فيها الامكانيه بس اذا كانت فقط
لحشر شعب ضد شعب او الانتقام قيمه ضد
الثاني انا بدونها كله بالفشل
ما بتقدر تحشر العالم شكرا جزيلا اهلا
وسهلا بك بس راح صوتي الله يعطيك العافيه
اخلي كل صوت الله شكرا لكم وشكر كذلك
لمركز الملك فيصل للبحوث والدراسات
الاسلاميه اللي كان جورج صريبك ضيفا عندهم
في برنامج وساعدنا في الوصول اليه والشكر
كذلك ايمن الحمادي وسالم برب في عداد
الحلقه وحكم موسى في التصوير ضياء الدين
المدني في الهندسه الصوتيه وانس الخليل في
تحرير هذه الحلقه وعبد المجيد الع باس في
التلوين وفي اداره التحرير اسيل هذا فنجان
احد منتجات شركه المانيا للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الانتاج بحب من مدينه الرياض
الاسبوع المقبل
يوتيوب بدك تشيل منهن بس لازم تستشيرني
اللي بدك تشيلهم
احنا ما بنحذف حاجه
تنزل زي ما هي
حلوه
ساعتين راح يضجر الانسان
قبل شهرين
مدتها ثلاث ساعات
عدد مشاهدات عليها الان 27 مليون
فحكي جميل الناس تسمع
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
[ضحك]
المشرق الطبيعي المشرق الطبيعي انه لا
اكثر من 25 دقيقه اذا وصلت لخمسه واربعين
دقيقه بتكون
العالم من الموت هذه السرديه كلاسيكيه
بديله
اذا متضايق تحبب العالم بالحليب بنضل
نتجمع الله يسعد قلبك شكرا والله اهلين
جدا
بعد عندك شي اعتراض
مثل المراقب الامم المتحده
تراقب ولا تتدخل عفاف هل هو متحد هيك
بيعمل ههه